welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today marks the second episode
in our Journal Club series with myself
and Dr Peter AA Dr Peter AA as many of
you know is a medical doctor who is a
world expert in all things Health span
and lifespan he is the author of the
bestselling book outlive as well as the
host of his own terrific podcast the
drive for today's episode Peter and I
each select a different paper to share
with you we selected these papers
because we feel they are both extremely
interesting and extremely actionable
first I present a paper that is about
how light exposure during the morning
and daytime as well as dark exposure at
night each have independent and positive
effects on Mental Health as well as the
ability to reduce the symptoms of many
different mental health disorders now
I've talked before on this podcast and
elsewhere about the key importance of
seeing morning sunlight as well as
trying to be in dim light at night
however the data presented in the paper
today really expands on that by
identifying the key importance of not
just morning sunlight but getting bright
light in one's eyes as much as is safely
possible throughout the entire day and a
separate additive effect of being in as
much Darkness at night as POS possible I
describe the data in a lot of detail
although you do not need a background in
biology in order to understand that
discussion and there's a key takeaway
which is that if you can't get enough
light in your eyes during the daytime
you would be well advised to get as much
Darkness exposure at night in other
words light and dark have independent
and additive effects on mental health
and during today's discussion you'll
learn exactly how to apply light
exposure and dark exposure in order to
get those benefits then then Peter
presents a paper about novel treatments
for cancer I must say it's an extremely
important conversation that everybody
regardless of whether or not you may
have had cancer or know somebody who's
had cancer ought to listen to he
highlights the current technology of
cancer treatments as well as the future
technology of cancer treatments and the
key role that the immune system and the
autoimmune system play in treatments for
cancer I assure you that by the end of
today's Journal Club episode you will
have learned
a ton of new information about light and
dark and mental health as well as cancer
and the immune system and treatments for
curing cancer before we begin I'd like
to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is eight sleep
eight sleep makes Smart mattress covers
with cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity I've spoken many times before
in this podcast about the fact that
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance now a
key component of getting a great night's
sleep is that in order to fall and stay
deeply asleep your body temperature
actually has to drop by about 1 to 3
degrees and in order to wake up feeling
refreshed and energized your body
temperature actually has to increase by
about 1 to 3° one of the best ways to
make sure that those temperature changes
occur at the appropriate times at the
beginning and throughout and at the end
of your night when you wake up is to
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment and that's what eight sleep
allows you to do it allows you to
program the temperature of your mattress
and sleeping environment such that you
fall and stay deeply asleep easily and
wake up each morning feeling incredibly
refreshed and energized I've been
sleeping on an eights Sleep mattress
cover for almost 3 years now and it has
dramatically improved the quality of my
sleep so much so that when I travel and
I'm at a hotel or an Airbnb and I don't
have access to my eight sleep I very
much look forward to getting home
because my sleep is always better when I
sleep on my eight Sleep mattress cover
if you'd like to try eightsleep you can
go to 8sleep.com
huberman to get $150 off their pod three
mattress cover eight sleep currently
ships in the USA Canada UK select
countries in the EU and Australia again
that's 8sleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by better help better help offers
Professional Therapy with a licensed
therapist carried out online now I've
been going to therapy for well over 30
years initially I didn't have a choice
it was a condition of being allowed to
stay in school but pretty soon I
realized that therapy is extremely
valuable in fact I consider doing
regular therapy just as important as
getting regular exercise including
cardiovascular exercise and resistance
training which of course I also do every
week the reason I know therapy is so
valuable is that if you can find a
therapist with whom you can develop a
really good report you not only get
terrific support for some of the
challenges in your life but you also can
drive tremendous insights from that
therapy insights that can allow you to
better not just your emotional life and
your relationship life but of course
also the relationship to yourself and to
your professional life to all sorts of
career goals in fact IC therapy is one
of the key components for meshing
together all aspects of one's life and
being able to really direct one's focus
and attention toward what really matters
if you'd like to try better help go to
betterhelp.com huberman to get 10% off
your first month again that's
betterhelp.com
uberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by ju ju makes medical grade red
light therapy devices now if there's one
thing I've consistantly emphasized on
this podcast is the incredible role that
light can have on our biology and of
course I'm always telling people that
they should get sunlight in their eyes
as soon as possible after waking on as
many days of their life as possible for
sake of setting circadian rhythm daytime
mood focus and alertness and improve
sleep now in addition to sunlight red
light and near infrared light has been
shown to have positive effect effects on
improving numerous aspects of Cellar and
organ Health including faster Muscle
Recovery improved skin health and wound
healing even improvements in acne or
that is removal of acne reducing pain
and inflammation improving mitochondrial
function and even improving Vision
itself what sets juv apart and why it's
my preferred red light therapy device is
that it has clinically proven
wavelengths meaning it uses specific
wavelengths of red light and near
infrared light in combination that
trigger the optimal seller adaptations
personally I use the handheld ju every
day the handheld ju is about the size of
a thick piece of toast and I also own a
ju panel that allows for full body
exposure and I use that one
approximately five times per week for
about 10 to 15 minutes per session if
you'd like to try ju you can go to juv
spelled
jv.com huberman again that's jv.com
huberman for this month only January
2024 juv is offering exclusive discounts
to Huber lab listeners with up to $500
off select ju products again that's ju
spelled
jv.com huberman to get up to $500 off
select ju products and now for my
discussion with Dr Peter Atia Andrew
great to have you here for Journal Club
number two I'm already confident this is
going to become a regular for us I'm
excited I really enjoy this because I
get to pick papers I'm really excited
about I get to hear papers that you're
excited about and
we get to um sharpen our skills at
reading and sharing data and people
listening can do that as well so last
time I went first so uh I think I'm
going to put you on the hot seat first
and have uh have you go first and I'll
follow you okay well I'm really excited
about this paper um for a number of
reasons first of all it at least by my
read is a very powerful paper in the
sense that it
examined light exposure Behavior as well
as dark exposure behavior and that's
going to be an important point in more
than 85,000 people as part of this um
cohort in the UK um I'll just mention a
couple of things to give people
background and I'll keep this relatively
brief first of all there's a
longstanding interest in the
relationship between light and mental
health and physical health and we can
throw up
some very well agreed upon bullet points
first of all there is such a thing as
seasonal effect itive disorder it
doesn't just impact people living at
really Northern locations but basically
there's a correlation between day length
and mood and mental health such that for
many people not all but for many people
when days are longer in the spring and
summer they feel better they report
fewer depressive
symptoms and conversely when days are
shorter significantly more people report
feeling lower mood and affect Okay so
there's a long-standing treatment for
Seasonal effective disorder which is to
give people exposure to very bright
light especially in the
morning the way that that's normally
accomplished is with these sad lamps
Seasonal effective disorder lamps and
those lamps are basically bright meaning
more than 10,000 Lux lights that they
place on their kitchen counter or at
their table in the morning or in their
office so they're getting a lot of
bright light that is proven to be fairly
effective for the treatment of Seasonal
effective disorder what's less
understood is how light exposure in the
middle of the night can negatively
impact mood and health and so where we
are headed with this is that there seems
to be based on the conclusions of this
new study a powerful and
independent role of both daytime light
exposure and nighttime dark exposure for
mental health now a couple of other key
points the biological mechanisms for all
this are really well established there's
a set of cells in the neural retina
which aligns the back of your eye
they're sometimes called intrinsically
photosensitive retinal gangan cells
they're sometimes called melanopsin
retinal gangion cells we'll talk about
those in a bit of detail in a moment
it's well known that those cells are the
ones that respond to two different types
of light input not one but two different
types of light input and send
information to the hypothalamus where
your master circadian clock resides and
then your master circadian clock sends
out secretory signals so peptides
hormones but also neural signals to the
brain and body and say hey now it's
daytime now it's nighttime be awake be
asleep but it goes way beyond that these
melanops and intrinsically
photosensitive retinal gangling cells we
know also project areas of the brain
like the habenula which can trigger
negative affect negative mood they can
trigger the release of dopamine or the
suppression of dopamine the release of
serot in the suppression of do of
Serotonin and so they're not just cells
for setting your circadian clock they
also have a direct line literally one
synapse away into the structures of the
brain that we know powerfully control
mood so so the mechanistic basis for all
this is there so there's just a couple
of other key points to understand for
people to really be able to digest the
data in this paper
fully there are basically two types of
stimula that these cells respond to one
is very bright light as we just talked
about that's why getting a lot of
daytime sunlight is correlated with
elevated mood that's why looking at a
10,000 Lux artificial lamp can offset
Seasonal effective disorder by the way
just a couple questions on that um how
many Lux does the sun provide on a sunny
day at noon okay great question so if
you're out in the sun with no cloud
cover or minimal cloud cover in the
middle of the day at noon chances are
it's over 100,000
luck on a really bright day could be
300,000 Lux okay most indoor
environments even though they might seem
very bright I like to think of your
you're kind of like uh department store
with the bright lights believe it or not
that's probably only closer to 6,000 Lux
maximum and probably more like 4,000 Lux
most brightly lit indoor environments
are not that bright when it comes down
to Total Photon energy now here's the
interesting thing on a cloudy day when
you're
outside it can be as bright as or an
average of a 100,000 Lux but it won't
seem that bright because you don't quote
unquote see the Sun but it's also
because when there's cloud cover a lot
of those long wavelength of light such
as orange and red light aren't coming
through however and this is so important
the circadian clock the supermatic
nucleus it sums photons it's a photon
summing system so basically if you're
outside in 8,000 Lux very overcast UK
winter day and you're walking around
hopefully without sunglasses because
sunglasses are going to filter a lot of
those photons out your circadian clock
is summing the photons so it's an
integration mechanism it's not triggered
in a moment and actually the the
experiments of recording from these
cells first done by David buron at Brown
were you know historic in the field of
visual Neuroscience when shown bro
bright light on these intrinsically
photosensitive cells you could crank up
the intensity of the light and the
neurons would ramp up their membrane
potential and then start spiking firing
action potential long trains of action
potentials that have been shown to go on
for hours and so that's this signal
that's propagating into the whole brain
and body
okay so the the important thing to
understand is this is not a quick switch
that's why I suggest on non cloudy days
we'll call them that people get 10
minutes or so of sunlight in their eyes
in the early part of the day another 10
minimum in the later part of the day as
much sunlight in their eyes as they
safely can throughout the day but since
you're a physician I should just um and
you had a guest on talking about this
recently when the sun is low in the Sky
low solar angle sunlight that's really
the key time for we'll talk about in a
moment and when the sun is low in the
sky you run very very little risk of
inducing cataract by looking in the
general direction of the sun you should
still blink as needed to protect the
eyes it's when the sun is overhead and
there's all those photons coming in
quickly in one in a short period of time
that you do have to be concerned about
cataract and um macular degeneration if
you're getting too much daytime sunlight
so the idea is sunglasses in the middle
of the day are fine but you really
should avoid using them in the early and
later part of the day unless you're
driving into the Sun and you need you
know for safety reasons another question
Andrew if if a person is indoors but
they have large windows so they're
they're getting tons of sunlight into
their space they don't even need ambient
indoor light how much of the photons are
making it through the glass and how does
that compare to this effect yeah in
general unless the light is coming
directly through the
window most of the relevant wavelengths
are filtered out in other words if you
can't see the sun through the window
even if sufficient light is being
provided that's insufficient to trigger
this phenomenon that's right however if
you have um you know windows on your
roof which some people do skylights that
makes the situation much much better in
fact the neurons that in the eye that
signal to the circadian clock and these
mood centers in the brain reside mainly
in the bottom twoth thirs of the neural
retina and are responsible for looking
up basically they're Gathering light
from above
these cells are also very low resolution
so think of them as big pixels uh
they're not interested in patterns and
edges and movement they're interested in
how much ambient light there happens to
be now keep in mind that this mechanism
is perhaps the most well-conserved
mechanism in cellular organisms so there
and I'll use that as a way to frame up
the four types of light that one needs
to see every 24 hours for Optimal Health
and and when I say Optimal Health I
really mean mental health and physical
health but we're going to talk about
mental health mainly today in this
paper there's an absolutely beautiful
evolutionary story whereby single cell
organisms all the way to humans dogs
rabbits and everything in between have
at least two cone opson one that
responds to short wavelength light AKA
blue light and another one that responds
to longer wavelength light orange and
red so your dogs have this we have this
and it's a comparison mechanism in these
cells of the eye these neurons of the
eye they compare contrast between blues
and orange or sometimes blues and reds
and pinks which are also all long
wavelength
light there are two times of day when
the sky is enriched with Blues oranges
pinks and reds and that's low solar
angle sunlight at Sunrise and in the
evening these cells are uniquely
available to trigger the ex existence of
those wavelengths of light early in the
day and in the evening not in the middle
of the day so these cells have these two
cone photo pigments and they say how
much blue light is there how much red
light is there or orange light and the
subtraction between those two triggers
the signal for them to fire the signal
off to the circadian clock of the brain
and that's why I say look at low solar
angle sunlight early in the day what
that does is it what call it as phase
advances the clock this can get a little
Technical and we don't want to get too
technical here but think about pushing
your kid on a
swing the period of That Swing the
duration of That Swing is a little bit
longer than 12 hours okay so when you
stand closer to the kid so your kid
swings back and you give it a push
you're shortening the period right
you're not allowing the swing to come
all the way up that's what happens when
you look at morning sunlight you're
advancing your circadian clock translate
to English or non- nerd speake you're
making it such that you will want to go
to bed a little bit earlier and wake up
a little bit earlier the next
day in the evening when you view low
solar angle sunlight so in the a the
afternoon Setting Sun or evening Setting
Sun you do the exact opposite you're
phase delaying in the clock it's the
equivalent of your kid being at the very
top of the of the Ark and so it's gone
you know maybe 12 and a half hour uh 12
let's say 12 and a half hours is the
duration of that swing and you run up
and you push them from behind and give
them a little more push that's the
equivalent of making yourself stay up a
little later and wake up a little later
these two signals average so that your
clock stays stable You Don't Drift
meaning you're not waking up earlier
every single day or going to sleep later
every single day this is why it's
important to view low solar angle
sunlight in the morning and again in the
evening as often as possible and it's
done by that readout of those two photo
pigments now midday
sun which contains its bright light but
you see it as white light contains all
of those wavelengths at equal intensity
so the middle of the day is the
so-called circadian Dead Zone in the
middle of the day bright light triggers
the activation of the of the other opson
the melanopsin which increases mood
increases feelings of well-being has
some other consequences but you can't
shift your circadian clock by viewing
the sun in the middle of the day because
it's in the Circadian Dead Zone it's the
equivalent of pushing your kid on the
swing when they're at the bottom of the
Arc you can get a little bit more but
not much and in biological terms you get
nothing so this is why looking at
sunlight in the middle of the day is
great but it's not going to help anchor
your sleep wake cycle and if you think
about this is incredible right every
organism from single cells to us has
this mechanism to know when the sun is
rising and when the Sun is setting and
it's a color comparison mechanism which
tells us that actually color vision
Evolved first not for pattern Vision not
for seeing beautiful sunsets and
recognizing that's beautiful or
paintings or things of that sort but
rather for setting the circadian clock
now what if you only do one of these
Enders so what if you've got constant
exposure to low Morning Light but your
job prevents you from doing the same in
the evening or vice versa yeah a great
question better to get the Morning Light
because if if you have to pick between
low solar angle light earlier later in
the day and keep in mind if you miss a
day no big deal it's a slow integrative
mechanism average ing across the
previous two or 3 days but if you miss a
day you'll want to get twice as much
light in your eyes that next morning the
reason it's better to do in the morning
as opposed to the evening although both
would be to do uh best would be to do
both excuse me is that most people are
getting some artificial light exposure
in the evening anyway and here's the
Diabolical thing your retina is very
insensitive to light early in the day
you need a lot of photons to trigger
this mechanism early in the day as the
day goes on retinal sensitivity
increases and it takes very little light
to shift your circadian clock late in
the day keep in mind also that if you do
see afternoon and evening sunlight
there's a beautiful study published in
science science reports yes science
reports two years ago showing that that
can partially offset the negative
effects of artificial light exposure at
night I think of this as your Netflix
inoculation and the amount of melatonin
suppression from Nighttime light
exposure is haved by viewing even
Setting Sun now keep in mind you don't
need to see The Sun Cross The Horizon it
can just be when it's low solar angle so
you're looking for those yellow blue or
blue pink blue red contrast and on
cloudy days believe it or not they're
still there just you don't perceive as
much of it coming through so there
really so that's three things that we
should all strive to do view low solar
angle sunlight early in the day view
solar angle sunlight later in the day
and get as much bright light in our eyes
as we safely can ideally from sunlight
throughout the day
and if you can't do that get perhaps
invest in one of these uh sad lights
although they can be a bit expensive U
there are a couple companies that are
starting to design Sunrise simulators
and evening simulators that are actually
good that actually work um but right now
my read is that aside from one company
out there which by the way I have no
relationship to it's called the 20 light
tuo and that light bulb was developed by
the biologist at the University of
Washington who basically discover
covered these color opponent mechanisms
um those lights are not particularly
expensive but they're
um they do seem to work in fact they
they're the study that is emerging again
unpublished data seems to indicate that
if you look at it for more than five or
six minutes it can induce a mild
Euphoria that's how powerful this
contrast is and what they did there in
that light I'll just tell you the
mechanism is they figured out that when
most people look at low solar angle
sunlight in the morning they're getting
19 reversals of blue orange per second
so when you look at this light it looks
like a a barely flashing white light but
it's reversals of orange and blue orange
and um and you know red and blue and
it's happening so what what does the
person looking at it perceive um well
I've used one of these um it just looks
like a a flickering light and of course
there's the always the potential of a
placebo effect but well that's what I
was going to say is there a way to
control for that by having something
that looks the same to the user but of
course is not producing the same photo
effect yeah well they've done that with
the 10,000 Lux sad lamps and you and
which most people use to try and IND do
Sunrise simulation in their home but
keep in in mind that Sunrise is gives
you this comparison of short and long
wavelength light just a bright 10,000
Lux light triggers one of the options
that that but it won't set your
circadian clock so most of the sad lamps
that are out there are activating only
one of the mechanisms in these cells
that's relevant and not the one that's
most relevant so I'm excited about what
20 is doing I think that um and again I
have no relation to them except I know
the biologists who did the work that
that provide the mechanistic logic for
the that engineering I still think um
we're in the like the really like early
days of this stuff what should be done
is to have this stuff built into your
laptop right it should be built into
your phone and hopefully it will be now
I mentioned this color contrast thing in
sunrise and sunset I mentioned the
bright light throughout the day but
there's a fourth light stimulus that
turns out to be really important and
this will provide the segue into the
paper turns out that dark exposure at
night independent of light exposure
during the day is important for mental
health outcomes now most people think
dark exposure how do I think about that
well it is dark absence of light it's
the absence of light but what this paper
really drives home is that people who
make it a point to get dark exposure at
night aka the absence of light at night
actually benefit even if they're not
getting enough sunlight during the day
and this is especially true for people
with certain mental health issues so I
don't think we can overstate the value
of PR of accurately timed light exposure
to the eyes in the context of mental
health I think you know there's so much
data by now I will say however that some
people seem more resilient to these
light effects than others meaning some
people you know also don't suffer from
jet lag too much some people can stay up
late get a lot of bright light exposure
in the middle of the night and during
the day they got their sunglasses on all
day and they're in a great mood all the
time other people are more susceptible
these sorts of things and we don't know
whether or not gen polymorphisms underly
that I personally am very sensitive to
sunlight in the sense that if I don't
get enough sunlight I don't feel well
after a couple of days um but I'm less
sensitive to light exposure at night for
instance but I think it is
perhaps this is a big statement but is
perhaps the most
fundamental environmental stimulus for
levels of arousal and alertness which
correlate with all sorts of you know
neuromodulator and hormone outputs and
um so none of this should come as any
surprise I will mention one last thing
there was a study published gosh over 10
years ago now from Chuck iser Lab at
Harvard Medical School is a phenomenal
lab exploring circadian human health
behavior he's just considered a no pun a
luminary in the field but there wasn't a
study that was in error where they had
published in Science magazine that light
shown behind the knee could shift
circadian rhythms and that paper was
retracted um and a lot of people don't
know that it was retracted light
exposure to the eyes is what's relevant
here and as far as we know the color of
one's eyes like Darkness or lightness of
one's eyes Bears no relevance on their
sensitivity to these types of mechanisms
and on and on so so one question one
comment the question again is going back
to the morning evening light and I spend
a lot of time looking at those types of
skies for example just because of the
nature of my hobbies great right because
I'm always doing archery in the morning
and rucking in the afternoon so it's not
uncommon that I'm seeing both of those
how relevant is it that the Sun be above
the Horizon so for example um it begins
to get light about in 30 minutes before
sunrise and then you know right at so if
sunrises at
7:30 first light is is 7 and then you
know sort of 7:15 to 7 uh 30 is actually
quite bright I mean you can see anything
and everything and the same as true at
Sunset so does does that 30 minutes pre
or when sun is Beneath The Horizon
constitute part of that 10 minutes it
does I mean in an ideal circumstance
you'd get outside and see the sunrise
every day and you'd see the sunset every
day even on cloudy days some people like
myself wake up before the sun comes up
in which and I get this question all the
time well in the absence of powers to
make the sunrise faster which I'm not
aware anyone has certainly not me I
think the best thing to do is simply to
turn on as many Bright Lights as you can
indoors to trigger that melanopsin
mechanism if you want to be awake if you
want to stay asleep or sleepy then keep
them dim and then get outside once the
sun is starting to come out some people
wake up after the sun has risen right in
which case get what you can and some
people wake up 10 a.m. or noon in which
case you can still get the bright light
exposure but but you won't shift your
circadian clock now in the evening
especially in the winter months it's
important to look West and try and get
some sunlight in your eyes in the
evening if you've ever gone into the
clinic for instance at 2 o'clock in the
afternoon after lunch you know and then
in the winter and then come out and it's
dark when you're walk into your car it's
a kind of eerie feeling that sort of
eerie feeling May correlate with the
fact that you missed a signal your your
brain is trying to orient your brain and
body in time and that's what all of this
is right it's trying to orient in time
and again some people are more
susceptible to that than others some
people might like that um feeling of oh
I went in when it was bright and I come
out when it's dark but the vast majority
of people feel better when they're
getting this morning and evening
sunlight exposure and this is especially
important in kids all right this is one
of the things that you know this paper
points out and their good data that
people are spending approximately 90% of
their time indoors nowadays daytime time
time indoors and those indoor
environments are simply not bright
enough you think oh there's all these
bright lights and some people are
putting blue blockers on in the middle
of the day which is the worst thing you
could possibly do if you're going to
wear blue blockers and I don't think
they're necessary but if you're going to
wear them you'd want to wear them at
night and in the evening you don't need
to wear blue blockers you just simply
should dim the lights and ideally have
lights that are set a little bit lower
in your environment which the
Scandinavians have been doing for a long
time so you know kill the overhead
lights and don't obsess about bright
light exposure in the middle of the
night in fact for a long time I and some
other people were saying oh you know
even just a brief flash of light in the
middle of the night can you quash your
melatonin that's true but the other time
in which you're in the quote unquote
circadian dead zone is in the middle of
the night you can't shift your circadian
clock in the middle of the night but you
know all of this gets down to inter
weaving rhythms of light sensitivity
temperature hormone output cortisol it I
mean there's a whole landscape of
circadian biology this paper um which
was published in a new Journal I'm
really excited about called nature
mental health this journal was just
launched recently uh is entitled day and
night light exposure are associated with
psychiatric disorders and objective
light study in more than 85,000 people
now I have to say that I think the title
of this paper is terrible sorry folks at
nature mental health because if one just
read the title it sounds like day and
night light exposure associated with
psychiatric disorders right if this were
If This Were a newspaper headline You'
be like oh my goodness well what are you
supposed to do right but that's not the
conclusion the conclusion is that
getting a lot of sunlight exposure
during the day and getting a lot of dark
exposure at night is immensely
beneficial for psychiatric health and in
a number of ways now I'm not one to
bring up another paper unannounced but I
will say that this paper built off a
previous study entitled time spent in
outdoor light is associated with mood
sleep and circadian rhythm related
outcomes and that was a cross-sectional
longitudinal study in
400,000 biobank participants so this UK
biobank is an incredibly valuable
resource and there are now multiple
studies establishing that one's pattern
of light exposure is extremely important
now the previous study in
400,000 participants basically nailed
home the idea that the more time you
spend Outdoors
the better your is your mood the better
is your sleep the better is the
rhythmicity of your sleep wake cycles
and on and on something that I think
even though people will say we've known
that for thousands of years needed
scientific
substantiation this new study
essentially looked at the relative
contributions of daytime light exposure
and nighttime dark exposure and they did
that on a background of it looking in
particular at people who had major
depressive disorder generalized anxiety
PT SD bipolar
disorder he here's the the basic
takeaway and I'll I'll quote them here
and then I'll I'll tell you my
interpretation that here I'm quoting
avoiding night at light and seeking
light during the day I love that word
seeking may be a simple and effective
non-pharmacologic means for broadly
improving mental health so that's a
pretty bold statement right and I love
that they say seeking because it implies
that people aren't reflexively getting
the light exposure that they need that
this needs to be a practice ice much
like Zone 2 cardio or resistance
training okay so so what did they do in
this study so basically they gathered up
100,000 people or so it eventually was
paired down to about 86,000 participants
because some just didn't qualify or
didn't report their data back they
equipped them with accelerometers on
their wrist and those wrist devices also
could measure ambient light now that's
not a perfect tool because what you'd
love to do is measure ambient light at
the level the Eyes by the way will
somebody design an eyeglass frame that
changes color when you've gotten
sufficient light from sunlight during
the day and then and then at night is a
different color and then if you're
getting too much light exposure will go
to a different color frame this has to
be possible so that you don't have to
wonder if you got enough light during
the
day and of course if it's at the level
of the eyes then you know that's what's
landing at the eyes yeah and it's l i
mean that's what I was going to ask you
about that do these wrist based devices
potentially get covered by clothing and
some like turned you have your sleeves
down I have my sleeves up they had it on
the outside of the sleeve but they asked
that people just keep it on their
dominant hand it's not perfect but in
some ways it's kind of nice that it's
not perfect we could turn that
disadvantage into an advantage by
thinking you know when the person is out
and about they're not often looking
right at the sun you know if you're
talking to a colleague under an overhang
for instance so it's it's not perfect
directionally it's directionally right
okay and then they had two hypotheses
two primary hypotheses one that greater
light exposure in the day is associated
with lower risk for psychiatric
disorders and two second hypotheses
greater light exposure at night is
associated with higher risk for
psychiatric disorders and poorer mood
this is oh so relevant for the way we
live now people on screens and tablets
in the middle of the night okay then
they collected information about how
much light exposure people were getting
as well as their sleep and their
activity and so on I should mention this
was done in males and females it was a
slightly older cohort than one is used
to seeing people in their 50s and 60s
they had psychiatric diagnosis
information and then they divided people
into essentially two groups but they had
a lower so a q1 and a Q2 a lower cortile
that meant people that were getting less
daytime light as opposed to the third
and fourth quartile more daytime light
they also had a nighttime light
exposure evaluation and they had people
were in the low q1 and Q2 so these
people are getting less nighttime life
light versus Q3 Q4 more nighttime light
nicely they also looked at sleep
duration and they looked at photo period
meaning how long the days were for those
individuals how active they were what 10
hours a day 14 hours a day because the
more active you are the more opportunity
for light exposure you have during the
day or night for instance okay so it
they had I would say fairly complete
data sets then and I'm just going to
kind hit the top Contour of what they
did in each and sorry sleep duration
sleep efficiency Etc was determined off
the accelerometer that's right as well
as self-report yeah not not ideal right
you'd love for people to be wearing a
woop bander or or a ring or something of
that sort but this was initiated some
time ago so um they either didn't have
access to that technology or for
whatever reason didn't select
it I'd like to take a brief moment and
thank one of our sponsors and that's ag1
ag1 is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that also contains adaptogens I started
taking ag1 way back in 2012 the reason I
started taking it and the reason I still
take it every day is that it ensures
that I meet all of my quotas for
vitamins and minerals and it ensures
that I get enough Prebiotic and
probiotic to support gut health now gut
health is something that over the last
10 years we realized is not just
important for the health of our gut but
also for our immune system and for the
production of neurotransmitters and
neuromodulators like dopamine and
serotonin in other words gut health is
critical for proper brain functioning
now of course I strive to consume
healthy Whole Foods for the majority of
my nutritional intake every single day
but there are a number of things in ag1
including specific micronutrients that
are hard to get from Whole Foods or at
least in sufficient quantities so ag1
allows me to get the vitamins and
minerals that I need probiotics
prebiotics the adaptogens and critical
micronutrients so anytime somebody asks
me if they were to take Just One
supplement what that supplement should
be I tell them ag1 because ag1 supports
so many different systems within the
body that are involved in mental health
physical health and performance to try
ag1 go to drink a1.com huberman and
you'll get a year supply of vitamin D3
K2 and five free travel packs of ag1
again that's drink a1.com
huberman then what they did is they got
they have information on who has major
depressive disorder who has PTSD
generalized bipolar psychosis Etc and
then they ran three models and you can
tell me what you think about the power
of these models but you know as somebody
who thinks about the mechanistic aspect
of all of this a lot but not somebody
who's ever run this type of study I'd be
really curious model one examined the
unadjusted association between day and
nighttime light exposure and psychiatric
outcome so just basically asking is
there a relationship between how much
light you get it during during the day
and how much light you get at night and
how bad your or your depression is or
anxiety is ETC looking at you know just
a standard ratio of the probability that
you have a certain symptom or set of
symptoms versus you don't given a
certain amount of light exposure model
two adjusted for the age of the person
their sex and
ethnicity and photo period so they
looked at you know how long the days
were in that given person's region of
the
world and then model three these people
were all in the UK or were they around
the world they were all in the UK as far
as I know and then model three adjusted
for employment so employed versus
unemployed which if you think about it
is pretty important like you say well an
unemployed person has a lot more time to
control these variables but an employed
person who's doing shift work does not
right and they they Incorporated
information about employed versus
unemployed physical activity which turns
out to be very important and then things
like shift work etc and so these what
what we can say very safely is that the
outcomes with each of these models the
results were very similar so we don't
want to discard the differences between
those models entirely but in my read is
in every figure of the paper it doesn't
seem like model one two or three differ
from one another in terms of total
outcome yeah that's an unusual aspect of
this paper so so these adjustments are
very standard right so that's this is a
a classic uh tool that's used in most
epidemiology um because you don't have
randomization so once randomization is
out the window you know you you're like
so for example the paper I'm going to
present is based on an RCT there will be
no models it's just he the data right
yeah here they're asking people what
what do you do report back to us we're
going to measure your light exposure but
no one was assigned to any groups they
swapped there the the whatever quote
unquote controls are
there they're really not there it's just
comparisons between groups so what is
interesting to me uh is that as it's
exactly as you said and we'll make all
these figures available in addition to
the papers but um I mean there it's very
unusual that there's no difference
between the unadjusted and the adjusted
models and as you say there's probably
two places out of you know 30 when you
look at all the different quartile
comparisons where you might Creep from
you know statistically significant just
out of it or just into it but yeah you
could simplify this figure two
completely by just showing one of the
models and you would be you know getting
95% of the information which is you know
I mean I think in one way that
suggests that there's less dependency on
those
variables of course it still doesn't
address probably the greatest question
question I have here which I'm sure
we'll get to at some point as as you
continue yeah so I'm very curious what
that question is but I'll I'll I'll
suppress my curiosity for the moment you
know so if we look at figure two of this
paper and I realize a lot of people are
listening and and they're not able to
look at this although we have posted the
figures on the YouTube versions of this
uh just want to make clear what's going
on just for those that are listening
essentially what they're looking at is
what they call the odds ratio which is
the probability of something happening
in one group vers divided by the
probability of something happening in
another group I guess would it by way of
example be you know if you're going to
look at the odds ratio of you know the
probability of somebody getting lung
cancer if they smoke versus probability
somebody getting lung cancer if they
don't smoke so odds ratios and Hazard
ratios are often confused they're very
similar and odds ratios generally refer
to a lifetime exposure whereas a hazard
ratio is um defined over a specific
period of time but the MTH is still
effectively the same and uh using the
example you gave if you took the odds
ratio of um you know death so let's talk
all cause mortality for a smoker versus
a nonsmoker and the answer were 1.78 I'm
making that up but that's directionally
correct 1.78 as an odds ratio means
there's a
78% chance greater of the outcome of
interest in this case death by any cause
in the affected Group which would be the
smokers so odds ratio of two is 100% and
odds ratio of three is 200% so the math
is take the number subtract one and
that's the percent you know figure two
of this paper is one of the key
take-homes they essentially look at the
odds ratio of people who are in the
let's say that let's just look at the
nighttime light exposure and just remind
me Andrew CU and and everybody else
watching the every one of these is
showing second third fourth as your
x-axis meaning they're all being
compared to the first quartile that's
right and the first quartile is lowest
light exposure or highest light exposure
low well or well we have to um
differentiate between day and night
that's right okay so restate it sure so
uh if we look at you know what is your
risk of a psychiatric challenge broadly
speaking well panel a is is major
depressive disorder if you are in the
second quartile third quartile or fourth
quartile of nighttime light exposure so
second being the least amount of
nighttime light exposure third being
more nighttime light exposure and fourth
the most nighttime light exposure
relative to the first quartile this is
just a stupid thing like if I were doing
this figure if you were doing this in a
lecture you know what you would do to
make it so easy you would draw arrows on
it that say increasing light exposure at
night decreasing light exposure in the
day it's the same information it just
makes it easier for the reader to
understand absolutely but and maybe the
teaching point I think is is for people
when they review articles like don't be
afraid to do that and just kind of like
oh I've got all over this exactly so
it's like I I draw the arrow that's
increasing light that's decreasing light
and that's how I can pay attention to
what's actually happening right and I'm
actually in touch with the editorial
staff at nature at nature mental health
although they don't know that I'm
covering this paper until after this
comes out you know I think one thing
that scientific journals really really
need to do is start making the
readability of the Articles better for
nonex experts I mean chances are if you
can't understand a graph and this is
true for everybody chances are there's a
problem with the way it's presented yeah
put it on them but then of course try
and parse it because um you know rarely
if ever is it all spelled out clearly
but anyway that's what we're trying to
do here so yeah the way I would have
done is say second quartiles low amounts
of nighttime light exposure and Define
what that is you
know third quartile is more light
exposure and then fourth maximum amount
of light exposure at night and basically
what you see is that the probability of
having worse major depressive symptoms
linearly increases as you go from the
second to third to Fourth quartile so
more nighttime light exposure worse for
you and there's a dose response if you
will of the effect now we can March
through or describe figure two pretty
quickly by saying the same thing is true
now just talking about nighttime light
exposure for generalized anxiety
disorder so that's panel C bipolar
disorder although the difference between
the second and the third quartile in
bipolar disorder isn't as traumatic once
you get up to the fourth quartile
bipolar symptoms get much worse when
people are getting nighttime light
exposure I really want to emphasize that
point because they go on in the
discussion of this paper to reemphasize
that point several times in fact they
say that while light EXP exposure during
the day of course we will go into the
data is beneficial for mental health for
people with bipolar disorder it seems
that light exposure at night is
especially problematic independent of
how much sunlight they're getting during
the day so your bipolar um in the person
with bipolar disorder who's struggling
with either a manic or a depressive
episode who's making a point to get
sunlight during the day who's also
getting light exposure at night is
making their symptoms worse and keep in
mind they they couldn't completely
control this but is largely independent
of things like sleep duration so that
doesn't necessarily mean that the
person's sleeping less although in a in
a manic episode presumably they are it's
independent of exercise it's independent
of a bunch of other things because any
any logical person will hear this and
say okay well they're they G more light
at night because they're doing a bunch
of other things but it's largely
independent of those other things
likewise the symptomology of PTSD gets
far worse with increasing light exposure
at night
self harm really takes a a leap from
being fairly I don't want to say minimal
at the second and third quartile so low
and let's say medium I'm using some I'm
taking some Liberties here but low in
medium amounts of of artificial light
exposure at night than for people who
get quite a lot of nighttime light
exposure self harm goes up and
probability of Psych psychotic episodes
goes up or psychotic symptoms now what's
nice is that the
what's nice about the data is that the
exact inverse is basically true for
daytime light exposure although not
across the board we can generally say
that for major depressive disorder
generalized anxiety bipolar symptoms
there it's a little more scattered PTSD
and self harm the more daytime light
exposure ideally from sunlight because
that's actually what's being measured in
most cases we could talk about how we
know
that is going to approximately linearly
drop the probability or the severity of
these symptoms and we could just explain
again that the odds ratios now seem to
be going down so an odds ratio of 7 now
refers to a 30% reduction in the
variable of interest here exactly now
the The psychosis panel F which uh
focuses on psychosis I think is also
worth
mentioning in in a bit more detail
there's a fairly dramatic reduction in
psychotic symptoms as one gets more
daytime light exposure independent of
nighttime light
exposure there's a well-known phenomenon
called ICU psychosis which is that
people come into the hospital for a
broken leg or a car accident maybe they
were getting surgery from from Peter
back when for something totally
independent they're they're housed in
the hospital and as anyone who's ever
been in a hospital as a patient or
visitor knows the light in the lighting
environment of the hospital is
absolutely dreadful for health just
Dreadful I mean people often complain
about the food in the cafeteria as being
unhealthy that's often not always
true not always true but the lighting
environments in hospitals is absolutely
counter especially especially in the
Intensive Care Unit yeah right I think
the the Intensive Care Unit at Hopkins
the main one the the main sucku didn't
have Windows people who who go into the
hospital with with a brain injury or or
with a stroke or something I get
contacted all the time even though I'm
not a clinician what should I do for my
kid my parent my I say get them near a
window and start to the best of your
abilities controlling their sleep wake
cycle now often times there's there you
know nurses coming in and taking blood
tests and measuring pulses in the middle
of the night that's disruptive there
there's bright light not just blue light
that's disruptive it's noisy that's
disruptive ICU psychosis is when non
psychotic individuals start having
psychotic episodes in the hospital
because of nighttime light exposure and
in some cases lack of daytime
sunlight we can can say that with some
degree of confidence because when those
people go home even though sometimes
their symptoms for what brought them to
the hospital in the first place get
worse their psychosis goes away now and
it's independent of medication so let's
just be really
direct there is a possibility that we
are all socially jetlagged that we are
all disrupting these mood regulation
symptoms systems excuse me by not
getting enough daytime light and by
getting too much nighttime light if we
want to look at just some of the bullet
points of the takeaways and then Peter
thank you you highlighted a few of these
but can we just go back to this figure
two for a second there's a handful of
things that really was going to want to
want to dig in the DAT just um and and
again I normally wouldn't make so much
hay out of this except for the fact that
they're so tight um but the there are a
few that really stand out um and again I
love this figure um I would have labeled
it a little differently to make it
completely userfriendly but nevertheless
the increasing light at night and the
impact on
depression let let me be really
technical in what I say and the
relationship or correlation to
depression is very strong um the
relationship to light and self harm in
the upper cortile so when you take those
25% of people with the most nighttime
light that relationship to self harm is
interesting and completely uncoupled
from the other 75% that's interesting
but uncoupled you mean that at the lower
levels of light exposure at night you're
not seeing an increase in self harm not
what and then once you get to that
fourth quartile it's a big step it's
like a 30% greater risk of self yeah so
it's totally flat the first second third
quartile no different and then fourth
big jump um and then the the the inverse
relationship right as light increases
during the daytime you see this
reduction in self harm interesting the
PTSD relationship based on nighttime
light and The psychosis relationship
based on daytime light those are the
ones that really jumped out to me uh I
think anxiety
relatively the you know less impressive
here and and bipolar disorder didn't
seem as strong right as well so I think
those those are the big ones that that
jumped out to me yeah I agree there's
AIT there's a bit more scatter on
generalized anxiety and and the degree
of the sign the degree of significant
change is not is not as robust in other
words getting a lot of daytime light
ideally from sunlight is not necessarily
going to reduce your levels of anxiety
getting a lot of nighttime light
exposure is not increasing nighttime
anxiety that much although 20% you know
is is not nothing um for nighttime light
exposure but yeah where the psychosis
major major depression and self harm are
really you know they leap out actually
we maybe we even just drill a little bit
deeper on major depression basically
when you go from the second to third
quartile of nighttime light exposure so
more than nighttime light exposure you
basically go from no significant
increase to almost almost a 20% increase
and then as you get up to the fourth
quartile so the most nighttime light
exposure you're at about
25% increase in major depressive
symptoms not that's no joke um and you
know and I think that I think that we
you know if we were to uh know we don't
have the data right here but if we were
to look at like standard SSRI treatment
for major depression you know um people
debate this pretty actively but um light
is is a very potent stimulus and the
timing of light is critical because on
the the inverse is also true as you get
to the fourth quartile of daytime light
exposure you get about a 20% reduction
in major depressive disorder what I like
about a study like this is that it puts
the error bars so easy to see on the
data and why is that interesting well um
there's there's um there's a there's a
belief that bigger is always better in
sample size and we often talk about that
through the lens of power analysis right
so how many subjects do we need to um to
to reach a conclusion that is powered to
you know this level and that's that's
true but what I don't think gets
discussed as often is the opposite of
that which is what if you overpower a
study in other words what if the power
analysis says to be uh to have a level
of power at 90% you need a th000
subjects and you Sayre we're going to do
10,000 subjects well you're clearly
powered for it but you might be
overpowered and people might say well
why would that be a bad thing it could
be a bad thing because it means you are
very likely to reach statistical
significance in things that might not be
actually significant and so one thing
about this study that is just a quick
back like kind of a quick and dirty way
to tell that it's probably not
overpowered is that you have varying
lengths of error bars and what that
tells me is that and again this is not
like a formal statistical analysis it's
just kind of like a back of the envelope
statistical analysis if you look for
example at self harm in the top quartile
you actually have pretty big error bars
in fact all the self harm have sort of
slightly bigger error bars and yet when
you look at for example the depression
even though the a bars aren't all the
same size they're tighter in fact when
you look at the relationship between
depression and daytime light the air
bars are really really small so that
just gives me confidence that there is
variability in this which paradoxically
you kind of want to see because it tells
me that this wasn't just done you know
there was I think you said 8,000
subjects were in this and I realized 8
more than 86,000 86,000 sorry yeah you
realize that it wasn't that oh this
should have been done with a tenth of
that or a half of that and we're picking
up um signal that is statistically
relevant but clinically irrelevant yeah
thanks for for that point that I didn't
pay attention to that um I mean I paid
attention to the air bars but I didn't
know that um so thank you I'm learning
too and I I suppose for people that are
listening we can just give them a sense
of what the error bar ranges are for
self harm you know they're running you
know as much as 20% either side of the
the mean the average and for major
depression it looks like it's more like
let's say 8 to 10% if if that if that
maybe like five right so um yeah I see
what you're saying so when you get a a a
very large sample size you're going to
have some outliers in there and you can
mask those outliers just by having so
many data points right yeah because
these error bars directly tell you
whether or not your statistically
significant so what's really nice about
this type of graph and you see these in
there's going to be a graph in my paper
where you see the same analysis um
they're always drawing the 95%
confidence interval on the on the data
point and if the 95% confidence interval
does not touch the the line of unity
which in this case is the the the the
hods ratio of 1.0 or the x-axis then you
know it's statistically significant to
the confidence interval they've defined
which is almost assuredly 95% sometimes
they'll make it tighter at 99 and so
that's why you can just look right at
these and go oh look you know in
depression the second quartile didn't
reach statistical significance because
the error bars are touching the line
just as the case for the second and
third quartile for self harm but when
you look at the fourth quartile you can
see that the lower tip of the error bars
isn't anywhere near Unity and so we know
without having to look up the P value
that it's uh smaller than either 05 or
0.1 however they've defined it and it's
really amazing when you see these you
know overpowered studies which are
easier to do epidemiologically where you
know the P value ends up being
microscopic you know they can they can
drive their P values down to anything
low because sample size can be infinite
but you know you can see that it's just
like the the error bar is just skimming
above the uh the the unity line but it's
so so so tight I'd like to take a quick
break to acknowledge our sponsor element
element is an electrolyte drink that has
everything you need and nothing you
don't that means zero sugar and the
appropriate ratios of the electrolytes
sodium magnesium and potassium and that
correct ratio of electrolytes is
extremely important because every cell
in your body but especially your nerve
cells your neurons relies on
electrolytes in order to function
properly so when you're well hydrated
and you have the appropriate amount of
electrolytes in your system your mental
functioning and your physical
functioning is improved I drink one
packet of element dissolved in about 16
to 32 ounces of water when I wake up in
the morning as well as while I exercise
and and if I've sweat a lot during that
exercise I often will drink a third
element packet dissolved in about 32
ounces of water after I exercise element
comes in a variety of different flavors
all of which I find really tasty I like
the Citrus I like the watermelon I like
the raspberry frankly I can't pick just
one it also comes in chocolate and
chocolate mint which I find tastes best
if they are put into water dissolved and
then heated up I tend to do that in the
winter months because of course you
don't just need hydration on hot days
and in the summer and spring months but
also in the winter when the temperatures
are cold and the environment tends to be
dry if you'd like to try element you can
go to drink element spelled lm.com
huberman to try a free sample pack again
that's drink element.com
huberman one thing that I hope people
are taking away from this study is that
imagine you're somebody who has a very
sensitive circadian mood system well
that would mean you need less daytime
light exposure to feel good or less bad
but it also means that you might need
very little light at night in order to
negatively impact your mood systems and
in fact they make this argument in the
discussion as an interesting point that
I think is worth mentioning what because
here what I again what I like about the
study is that they've separated day and
nighttime light
exposure turns out that many of the
drugs that are used to treat bipolar
disorder reduce the Sens are are
effective perhaps in part because they
reduce the sensitivity of the light
sensing circadian apparati now that's
interesting right if if you think about
this okay so these are drugs that can
ameliorate some of the symptoms of
bipolar perhaps in part by reducing the
extent to which nighttime light exposure
can relieve bipolar symptoms can excuse
me can exacerbate bipolar
symptoms conversely there's evidence
that people who take take certain
anti-depressants May suppress the
ability for daytime light to positively
impact the mood systems of the brain now
of course we don't want people halting
their medication on the basis of that
statement alone please don't you know
talk to your psychiatrist but if we know
one thing for sure it's that if you want
a significant outcome and a paper as a
scientist give a drug any drug and look
at the amount of rapid eye movement
sleep or the Circadian cycle pretty much
any drug Alters the Circadian
rhythm for better or worse but if we
start to think about which medications
might adjust our overall sensitivity to
light sometimes this could be a good
thing you think less sensitivity to
light well for people who have bipolar
disorder the amount of daytime light
exposure isn't that important for their
overall mood regulation but the amount
of nighttime light exposure really is in
other words Darkness for eight hours
every night should be viewed in my
opinion as a treatment for bipolar
disorder not the only treatment but it's
also clear that we should all be
avoiding really bright extensive really
bright nighttime light exposure I mean
if if anything you know my take away
from this study is that Darkness at
night is the fourth key light stimulus
now a couple of things very bright
Moonlight very bright candle light is
probably only
like gosh three to 50 lucks what when
you go outside on a brightly lit full
moon night I encourage people to
download this free app I have no
relationship to it called light meter
and it gives you a pretty good read of
what the lucks are in that environment
by the way a lot of people don't realize
this they think you just tap the button
and then it tells you how many lucks you
hold it down it's kind of fun you can
scan around the room and see how many
lucks are on average coming from that
location or outside go out on a really
bright moonl night I mean we we should
have a full moon tonight yeah let's do
it you're not going to get above a 100
Lux that's incredible you're sitting at
a candlelight dinner with your spouse or
with friends and it's clearly bright
enough to see them put that lux meter
right up not too close to the flame 50
to 200 Lux i i 4 interesting experience
a couple of months ago on an elk hunt
where it was a full moon which actually
makes the hunting not so great but it
was the first time I've ever noticed my
shadow in relation to the Moon uh that's
how bright it seemed the light was this
is Halloween appropriate since we're
coming out we we're recording this close
to Halloween it's remarkable super
interesting to think it could be that
dim campfire you know and Fire Light you
think okay gathering around a campfire
then okay you know everyone circadian
rhythm must have been disrupted for ages
before the development of of electric
electricity no no that th those
campfires are extremely bright but
they're they're they're not they're not
that bright compared to a very densely
overcast day and what is is your phone
if you don't use any sort of uh light
mitigating uh Tech on it well distance
matters um at the distance we're holding
it yeah with so with all the the
wavelengths cranked up so no uh there is
a nice feature intrinsic to the phone
where you can eliminate the blues at
night or you know this kind of thing but
if you crank it up to maximum light
intensity probably something like you
know 500 to 1,000 Lux now keep in mind
though it's additive right so it's over
time so Lux is a measure of I think I
think it relates back to Candelas it's
the amount of light um shown at I think
it's like the the one meter away and
there's a squaring and a falling off of
distance we can look it up um these are
old measurement old school measurements
converted to Lux but keep in mind that
if you're looking at your phone or
tablet at 800 Lux or 500 Lux in the
evening you do that for 2 hours well
you're summing quite a lot of photons
now it is true and I I I I do want to be
fair to the biology uh and it'd be
dishonest to say anything different you
know we we've hammered on people about
not shifting their circadian rhythm with
light at night but we know that the
middle of the day and the middle of the
night are circadian dead zones you can't
shift your circadian rhythm that well in
the middle of the day and the middle of
the night but you can provide a wakeup
signal for for your body and brain it's
really that sunrise and sunset that are
critical that's why I said there are
four things see sunrise or sunrising you
don't need to see across the Horizon
Sunset bright light during the day
minimize light exposure at night and you
don't need Pitch Black in fact pitch
black probably just increases the
frequency of injury you know I get up in
the middle of the night to use the
bathroom probably once I think it's
normal I go back to sleep you know if it
were pitch black I'd probably injure
myself so just just dim it down some
people use red lights you know our
friend Rick Ruben yeah Rick ruin is uh
can we tell a funny story about Rick
yeah of course of course you know this
story but just I just in casee Rick's
listening he'll appreciate this you know
when Rick was uh here staying last
summer um he's up in our guest house and
he came down after the first night and
he was like unacceptable you know what
I'm talking about unacceptable
accommodations what did he do he removed
all the lighting that existed in that
room and replaced it with red light
bulbs which I later used when I stayed
here and then later stole when I
left the teenage me I took them I took
him that's why Derek when he stayed here
lane or anyone else when he stayed here
Cony or anyone else didn't have those I
took them I love them so funny Jill is
like you know Rick changed every light
in the guest house to Red I'm like yeah
no I didn't know that but I'm not
surprised yeah well in his place he has
mostly either no lighting or red
lighting so during the day he just goes
by ambient light um and then red light
in the evening and or candle light and
it's great and you know people hear red
lights and they think they have to buy
these expensive red light units that's
not what we're talking about that you
can literally buy red party lights or
just a red bulb some people say well can
I just use a red film or can I put a
t-shirt over the lamp I worry about
people putting t-shirts over lamp
because of the fire hazard um but I'll
be honest I dim the lights in my home at
night um when I travel sometimes I will
bring one of the the stolen from Rick
Rubin red lights the red the Rick rubben
stash here's something where I've I've
sort of softened my tune so I used to be
kind of a hard liner no blue light in
the evening guy um you know had the you
know everything was red light at night
as far as my phone using flux on the
computer you know whatever it was
um I suspect that that matters somewhat
but I think what matters more is the
stimulation that may come from those
things and what I've come to realize at
least in me which means it probably is
true in others as well and at least some
others is that what I'm doing on my
phone matters more than how how bright
my phone is in other words if I've got
the best blue light filter in the world
on my phone but I'm doom scrolling
social media and getting lit up on email
that's way worse for me than if I've got
my phone on maximum light and I'm like
watching YouTube videos of F1 cars and
driving around having fun like it's a
totally different experience so so so
the context matters and um I think I
think for that reason I I I would want
people to be mindful of the whole
picture um you know going to bed under a
period of you know intense duress
brought on by something you know that's
an equally dangerous component to all of
this that's that's distinct from what
we're talking about but but you know you
just want i' like I want people to be
able to think of this in the context of
everything yeah I it's a really
important point you know one thing I'll
say is that if you're going to stay up
past your normal bedtime if you're going
to get a lot of light in your eyes I
would hope that it would be for fun
reasons and for reasons you enjoy you
should definitely spend some nights out
you should definitely do some all
nighters studying if you really you know
if you if it's going to help you get the
grade that's permanent right I'd
certainly have done all nighter studying
and grant writing for years um you know
there are going to be the inevitable
allnighters due to God forbid a Hos trip
to the hospital or you heard something
on the news that really amped you up or
you just simply can't sleep that stuff
is going to happen so I think the goal
should be to minimize light exposure at
night and I think what you just said is
especially true because we don't know
for instance people talk about the
negative impact of social media is it
the fact that people are looking at this
little box for so many hours per day is
it all the things they're not doing is
it what they're looking at per se all of
those things interact and are really
important I we know based on studies
from the Stanford sleep lab that if you
wake up in the middle of the night
looking at what time it is can be very
disruptive to your ability to fall back
asleep and to your sense the next day
it's just a placebo effect but it's a
powerful one of how tired you are the
next day they've done this where they
wake people up in the middle of the
night and then they say it's you know
4:00 a.m. versus 2: a.m. versus 6:00
a.m. and people's perceived levels of
energy during the day in some ways
correlate with what they think how much
sleep they think they got likewise and
this is one of the concerns potential
concerns with sleep trackers yep Ali
Crum talked about this when she came on
our podcast you know if people see a
poor sleep score they often feel worse
than if they see a good sleep score now
of course physiology matters you can't
lie to yourself and say you you know got
a great night of sleep simply by virtue
of a sleep score but I worry more about
the the
false well I if it's a false negative
that we don't want to put veilance on
this seeing a bad sleep score and then
deciding that you're going to have a
terrible day you know I think a bad
sleep score is an indication that you
might need to dial some things in a bit
better getting a great sleep score is an
indication that you might be doing a
number of things right and start looking
at these things as averaging wouldn't
would you agree yeah completely I I I I
don't think it's that different from CGM
right like I think that CGM is an
amazing tool to provide insight and you
pretty much know the insights after a
relatively short period of time 30 days
maybe at the outside 90 for for a really
per for a person with a very complicated
life um and you know all you need to
know about how the inputs affect the
output thereafter if you choose to use
it it's a behavioral tool in other words
you're using this to build in a Hawthorn
effect I think the same is largely true
with sleep trackers um most people have
this profound sense of learning when
they first encounter one of these things
and and it's again you've heard it all
100 times oh my God I can't believe what
alcohol does to my sleep right or
caloric trackers exactly like I think a
lane Norton's app carbon I have no
Financial relationship to it I use it or
and it's taught me wow like I consume a
lot of calories in the form of certain
things at certain times of day and
there's just a lot of good learning in
that but it's the Act of tracking that
helps you manage it and similarly I
think it's the act of knowing you're
going to be looking at that score that
gamifies it that kind of helps people do
the right things oh you know what I'm
not going to have that drink tonight or
I'm not going to eat that snack before
bed because I've now been conditioned to
see how that impact score that said I
think that um you know recovery scores
and things like that are just
notoriously poor at predicting
performance and I think there's a reason
that serious athletes would never use
things like that um they would tend to
rely on the more tried and true methods
of predicting Behavior such as heart
rate uh maybe heart rate variability but
morning resting heart rate probably more
predictive than anything else and then
you know inw workout things such as
heart rate heart rate recovery lactate
threshold things like that so yeah I
agree I think we have to and I say this
as a guy who's generally perceived to be
the most Pro device guy in the world
people would be surprised how sparingly
I use things like that
I mean I do some Tracking not as much as
you uh I
love things that seem to work the first
time and every time in terms of our
natural biology based on a couple of
criteria there's an established
mechanism um it's been explored in the
context of pathology like mental health
disorders as well as pro- health in
healthy individuals um that it make
really good sense at the level of kind
of um uh Wellness uh uh and let's just
say ancient Health you know when you're
talking about getting a lot of sunlight
during the day like a lot of people say
well of course get outside and play not
getting too much light at night of
course this is just good old quote
unquote good oldfashioned advice people
spend 90% of their time indoors now
their daytime environments are too dim
their nighttime environments are too
bright and this kind of misleading
aspect of artificial light that when you
see a bright bulb you think I'm getting
a a lot of photons is part of the
problem and the fact that when you're
out on a overcast day and it you know
you think there Sun quote unquote isn't
out well it's hidden by cloud cover but
just think about how well you can
navigate that environment without a
flashlight yeah versus at night where
you would require a flashlight we
evolved under this tramatic difference
in day night availability of photons
independent of whether or not you can
quote see the sun and it's just very
clear that our the all the mechanisms in
our brain and body that regulate mood
are just powerfully regulated by this
stuff so I've made it a point to really
reduce the amount of nighttime light
that I'm getting but I am less concerned
about flipping on the light switch to
use the bathroom as I used to be I used
to think oh I'm like quashing all my
melatonin this is terrible I know I
can't shift my circadian clock then I
know that that light yes while it's
bright if it's brief I'm not going to
worry about it too much would it be
better to have a you you know a dim
light on as opposed to a bright light
sure but I'm not going to stress it in a
hotel bathroom or something I'm not
going to walk around you know shielding
my eyes people sometimes ask me by the
way is it different to look at the phone
directly versus if you tilt the phone
away well it absolutely is I mean think
about a flashl shown on the ground in
front of you very few photons getting in
your eyes versus shown directly into
your eyes think about the ambient light
from the Sun going everywhere versus
looking in the general direction of the
Sun so East in the morning West in the
afternoon of course
the directionality of the light matters
so I'm not saying it you know that you
need to like peek at your phone as if
you're looking you know over the edge of
a bowl or something into it but my
friend Samar hataru is head of the
chronobiology unit at the National
Institutes of mental health we used to
room together at meetings we stopped
because he's a terrible snorer so I just
could I there were a few times when I
considered suffocating him in the middle
of the night since he was already
suffocating himself now we just we don't
stay in the same rooms anymore we're no
longer postt talk
but I caught him looking at his phone in
the middle of the night and he would
tilt it like away like he's holding a
platter for those are just listening and
and kind of like looking over at the
screen there I'm like what are you doing
this is ridiculous he said I'm trying
not to get so much light in my eyes
that's a little extreme but I think it
illustrates the point which is how much
direct light exposure you get at night
matters how much direct sunlight
exposure you get especially early in
late early morning late afternoon and
throughout the day it really matters now
remind me Andrew what is the wavelength
of sunlight great so sunlight is going
to include all visible visible which
runs from how many yeah so well let's
let's we can answer two questions there
this wrist sensor detected 470 degree 70
nanometer to 650 nanometer light so
that's going to be blue and UltraViolet
ultraviolet is kind of kind of like blue
to Orange yeah blue blue to Orange
that's what this was measuring so red
light is going to be more like 680 um
far red is getting out to 7 720 and up
upwards of that blue light is going to
fall somewhere in the you know low fours
ultraviolet is getting down into the
high 3es and and lower um and so these
these Spectra of light so during the day
you know midday light you're get what
looks like white light you'll see oh the
sky is blue in the Sun is bright white
light it's not even yellow to your eye
and of course don't stare at it
especially in the middle of the
day you're getting all visible Spectra
so you're getting everything from UV all
the way out to Red Light it's just
coming in at equ intensities so is that
a potential limitation of this study in
that it didn't have a sensor that could
pick up the full spectrum of light
potentially especially since they're you
know we don't think of humans as UV uh
capable like we can't perceive UV light
um like a a ground squirrel for instance
can has UV sensors in its eyes turns out
you know why they use this it's crazy
they actually you know when the ground
squirrels sit up on their hunches
they're actually signaling one another
they rub urine on their belly and it
reflects UV um the the New York Times
for some reason has been running a
series of papers uh or articles rather
about uh naturally occurring fluoresence
at night in all sorts of scorpions and
uh monotes like the Platypus no one
really knows the reason for these odd
odd wavelength of light emissions for
for all these animals but you know we
view things in the blue violet and up to
red and you know we're not pit vipers we
can't see far red but we can see lower
than 470 nimet and we can see higher
than uh 7 650 is there a technology
reason why they had such a narrow band
in these sensors is it not possible that
they could have used a wrist sensor that
was wider this study was initiated in
2013 the tech was probably far worse
than it is now again I would love for
somebody to design an eyeglass where
it's measuring how many photons you're
getting across the day I'm not a big fan
of having everything be app IED so I
would love it if the frame would just
shift color across the morning like you
go outside on a cloudy day you know you
wear these glasses and um and by the way
it's fine to where eyeglasses or
contacts for sunlight viewing for
setting your circadian rhythm um people
always say well why is it that okay and
a window is not well corrective lenses
are actually focusing the light onto
your retina the windows and and
windshields are scattering the light and
filtering and how much are sunglasses
filtering this out way too much we can
safely say way too much probably causing
it
tfold decrement in the total Lux count
that's landing on your retina but of
course I you know sunglasses are
important driving into into sun and um
and some people have very sensitive eyes
I can't sit at a cafe with a bright
brightly reflective table in the
afternoon I just I just squint like
crazy I can't do it my dad who's you
know darker eyed you know he's South
South American descent he um you know he
can just sit there just fine my mom
who's got light eyes like me and you
know we're like oh it's really tough
just have a terrible time um you know
people differ in their light
sensitivity so there's one other macro
question I have here and it's not
answerable because without randomization
we can't know it but it's the question
of how much reverse causality can exist
in these observations so again these
observations um demonstrate very tight
correlations very strong associations
especially in the five areas that we
highlighted um
but it's possible that part of what
we're
seeing um is reverse causality brought
on by both the treatments which you've
already kind of alluded to and also the
condition itself do you want to explain
reverse causality for people and maybe
could you mention um for those that
missed uh the Hawthorne effect just yeah
yeah the the Hawthorne effect uh is is
is an effect that is named after you
know an observation of what took place
in a factory where they were actually
studying worker productivity with light
of all things um but what refers to is
the idea that people will change their
behavior when they are observed so if um
if I said well I really want to know
what a day in the life is like for
Andrew huberman I'm going to follow him
around for a day it's very unlikely that
his behavior that day will be exactly as
it was if I wasn't there re why you
probably will never see a day in the
life of Andrew huberman although it's
pretty it's pretty scripted unless I'm
traveling it's a it's a you know it's
morning sunlight hydration and you know
some cardio or weight training and then
a lot of time reading papers it'd be the
most boring video in the world because
mostly me reading and underlining things
but it's why um gamifying things can be
beneficial right it's why a CGM can can
be beneficial because it's sort of like
somebody's watching you and you're going
to modify what you eat in response to it
or why tracking can really be an
effective way to reduce input because
you there's a sense of being monitored
by doing that especially if someone
literally monitors it in other words you
can set up an accountability partner
where your health coach or someone is
actually seeing the data so that's what
it is now as far as reverse causality
when you look at variables so
um let's just pick u a common one that's
unrelated to this so there there's an
association that more diet soda
consumption is associated with greater
obesity it's a bit paradoxical right um
is that true it is yeah it's it's been
demonstrated in many series that the the
the greater the consumption of diet soda
the greater the prevalence of obesity
and that has been postulated by some to
suggest that non-nutritive sweeteners
such as aspartame or sucrose or things
like that are actually part of what's
causing
obesity um and while while there are
probably some arguments you could make
around the impact that those things
might have on the gut microbiome and
maybe there's some way and that's
happening it's also equally likely if
not probably more likely that there's
reverse causality there that a person
who is obese is therefore contemplating
how much they're eating or thinking hey
what's an easy way that I can reduce
calories how about instead of drinking a
Coke I drink a Diet Coke and so there
the causality which you would impute to
mean the drink is causing the Obesity it
might be no the Obesity is causing the
choice of drink so here the question is
um how much of the effect we're seeing
is a result of the condition that's
being studied right how much of the
disruption in both day and night ex uh
light exposure is the result of the
depression it's disregulated the sleep
maybe they sleeping more during the day
and more awake at night because of
depression again these are you can't
know this this is where epidemiology
never allows us to determine this and
sadly these questions can only be
answered through either direct
randomization or mandelian randomization
which by the way I was going to also ask
you do you know if anyone has examined
this from a mandelian standpoint that
would be that would be very interesting
because I have to
believe well it would be interesting I
don't know enough about the biology to
know what Snips would be studi but that
would be interesting what Peter is
saying is you know if you knew something
about the genomes of these
people um you would be in a great
position to perhaps even link up light
susceptibility genes or light light
sensitivity genes with genes for you
know Pathways involved in major
depression bipolar I mean get getting to
this issue of reverse causality I mean I
think it's very straightforward to
imagine that the person who's
experiencing a manic episode is going to
be up for two weeks at a time um sadly
and getting a lot of nighttime light
exposure you know now dark nighttime
dark exposure as a treatment for bipolar
is something that people are starting to
talk about so making sure that even
those people are awake that they're at
least blue blocking at night um reducing
their online activities but people with
severe manic episodes have a hard time
regulating their own behavior of course
and it's not one or the other like I
don't want the question to come across
to the listener that it has to be one or
the other it's only a can cause b or B
can cause a no it's actually a lot of
times these things feed off each other
going back to the soda example I
actually think there's a bit of both
right I I actually think there's a real
clear um body habitus dictates beverage
choice but I also am starting to think
that um ins susceptible individuals
non-nutritive sweeteners will alter the
gut biome and that alters metabolism
what about just hunger I I remember Lane
telling me and I I've seen at least at
least one of the studies that you know
water is probably better for us than
diet soda but that for some people diet
soda is a great tool for reducing
caloric intake I also know some
individuals not me who drink diet soda I
I drink diet soda from time to time
mainly Stevia sweeten sodas but but what
I'm referring to here are people besides
myself who drink diet soda and it seems
to stimulate their appetite there's
something about the the the perception
of sweet as driving hunger whereas not
eating uh or drinking anything with
calor with any sweetness doesn't seem to
this is one of the things I I wonder um
if it impacts why some people like
intermittent fasting because for some
people you know just even the the
perception I wonder if the perception of
sweetness or this even just the smell of
food we know can stimulate appetite so
you can imagine the perception of
Sweetness in the mouth even if there's
no calories there um I don't think it
necessarily makes people hypo glycemic
but perhaps it makes them think about M
like sweet means food for instance for
years I love the combination of a Diet
Coke and a slice of pizza whenever I was
in New York ideally two slices of pizza
so now every time I have a Diet Coke
which isn't that often but I like Diet
Coke especially with a little bit of
lemon in it I just think about a slice
of cheese or mushroom or pepperoni pizza
it's like I want it I crave it more so
there's a parot Association there that I
think is real and we know based on Dana
Small's Lab at Yale that there's this
paired association between the uh
sweetness from sucralose and there's an
insulin response they actually had to
Cease the study in kids because they
were they were becoming pre-diabetic you
know which unfortunately meant the study
was never published have you talked to
Dana on this podcast no we we wrote a
premium newsletter on this um several
months ago it it's got to be like I
don't know 10 to 20,000 words on all
things related to sugar substitutes I'll
read that so yeah folks who are
interested in this topic um I would
refer them to the premium newsletter on
sugar substitutes I think it was our
September Edition um the short of it is
the data are a little bit noisy um but
but there is indeed some some sweeteners
in some studies do do result in that
phenomenon you described the calic
insulin response
um and I came away from the research
that went into that which was Herculean
effort um on the part of the team
uh a little bit more confused than when
I went in
but um being even more cautious around
artificial sweeteners than I was going
in and not for the
reasons that I don't necessarily I don't
I didn't find any evidence that these
things are cancer-causing right so
that's the headline stuff people worry
about oh as like like 10 gr crazy I came
away more confident that from a from a
long-term safety perspective in terms of
met in terms of you know cancer and
catastrophic outcomes like that that
wasn't the issue but I came away much
more cautious around these things can
really be mucking around with both your
brain chemistry and your gut chemistry
which can pertain to your metabolism and
therefore my takeaway was buy or beware
use limited amounts only the one by the
way that still emerged to me is a
reasonable one it's the only one that I
use and I've talked about it a lot is
Xylitol xylitol is the pardon me I
shouldn't say that Xylitol for chewing
so for gum um and allulose as an
additive so those were the safer you're
saying yes those are those are basically
the only two I will consume yeah I'll
I'll drink a Diet Coke every now and
again if I'm on a plane or something you
know this law that got passed a few
years ago you couldn't bring liquids in
of your own into the airport and onto
the plane like what a great few years
ago what a great scheme what a great
scheme to get people to buy over
overpriced fluids in the airport like I
mean there are more important issues in
the world but like this one really gets
me um but yeah I I use a little bit I
drink things with a little bit of stevia
in it the occasional um Diet Coke um and
I I generally avoid sucrose I don't like
the way it tastes monk fruit is too
sweet but yeah we could we maybe we'll
do a a podcast on that in the future
okay so I think we can wrap this paper
because I really well but tell me what
you think about that point Andrew like
how I mean you know you you know more
about this stuff than I do but if if you
had to just lay on your judgment right
so so if it were if it were 100 to zero
you would say the light is 100% causal
in the effects we're seeing if it were
zero to 100 you'd say nope the behavior
is 100% causal of the exposure to light
where do you again you can't know it but
what does your intuition tell you okay
there's my intuition and then there's my
recognition of my own bias um because
you know I started working on these
circadian Pathways origin in the eye
back in year in 98 as a graduate student
at Berkeley the the cells these melanops
and intrinsically sensive retinal
gangling cells were discovered in the
early 2000s by a guy named Iggy
provencio Dave Bon Sam hatar sain panta
and others but and it was like one of
the most important discoveries in all of
biology clearly um so I've been very
excited about systems but if I set that
aside so um bias disclosure
made I think 65 to
75% of the effects are likely due to
light directly now it's impossible to
tease those apart as you mentioned but
to play Devil's Advocate against myself
you know you could imagine that the
depressed individual is laying around
indoors with the curtains drawn they
didn't sleep well the night before which
gives you a photo sensitivity that isn't
Pleasant like it sucks to have bright
light in your eyes first thing in the
morning if you especially if especially
if you didn't sleep well and then
they're you know making their coffee in
a dimly lit what they think is brightly
lit environment and then they're you
know looking at their phone and the the
state of the world sucks and their state
of their internal landscape is rough and
they're maybe they're dealing with a
pain or or you know injury or something
and their likelihood of getting outside
is is low and when they do get outside
they're going to shuffle and not you
know so I could see how the behaviors
could really limit the amount of of
light exposure and then evening rolls
around they've been tired all day and a
common symptom of depression you fall
asleep and then 2 or three in the
morning they're wide awake what are you
going to do at two or three when you're
Wide Awake sit in the dark no you're
going to get online you're going to
listen to things you might have I'm not
recommending this but a alcoholic drink
in order to try and fall asleep I mean
this is the pattern and so you know
shaking up that pattern is really what
what what so much of my public
health work these days is about and
trying to get people onto a more natural
daylight night uh night dark Rhythm uh
but yeah it's impossible to tease apart
we do know this and this is uh really
serious we know that in almost every
instance EV almost every Psychopathology
report of
suicide in the weeks but especially in
the days preceding suicide that person's
circadian rhythms looked almost inverted
from the normal
patterns and that's true of nonbipolar
individuals as well you know circadian
disruption and disruption in psychiatric
Health are
inextricable conversely positive mood
and affect and and circadian Behavior
seem very correlated I mean I think um
it's clear that if you want to become an
early riser get light in your eyes and
get activity in your body early in the
day you you built that you entrained to
those rhythms so that you start to
anticipate that morning workout you
start to anticipate the morning sunlight
just one um more scientific point we
know that when you view bright bright
sunlight in the morning or just sunlight
that's illuminating your environment as
you said you don't even have to see the
sun itself that there's a 55 z% increase
in the amplitude of the morning cortisol
Spike which is a good thing right that's
when you want it because it's inversely
the amplitude of the morning cortisol
spike is inversely related to the
amplitude of the evening cortisol Spike
and high evening cour is law is
associated with middle of the night
waking and on and on so um you know I'm
very bullish on these mechanisms I also
love that they're so deeply woven into
our evolutionary history you know that
we share with single cell organisms it's
so wild um but of course there's going
to be a bidirectionality there and it's
it's impossible to see where one thing
starts and the other one stops I mean
here's my take Andrew first of all I I
actually with far less Authority than
you um agree with your assessment and
might even be a little bit more bullish
might even put it at 8020 and and here
I'll I'll give you my explanations which
uh stem more from my fastidious battles
with epidemiology in general right like
because so much of the world that I live
in still has to rely on epidemiologic
data and so how do you make sense of it
and the truth of it is most of it is
really pretty bad um but I I tend to
find myself looking at the Austin
Bradford Hill criteria all the time and
for folks who don't know um he was a
statistician who basically proposed a
set of criteria U believe there are
eight of them and I can't believe I
don't know every one of them off by
heart I certainly used to um but the
more of these criteria that are met
within your correlations the more
likelihood uh you will find causality so
when I think of your data here the data
in this paper I'll tell you what makes
these correlations seem to have
causality within them in the direction
that's being
proposed um look at the dose effect so
dose effect matters and this is done in
quartiles and that's a very elegant
thing if they just did it as on off it
would be harder high low that's right
but the fact that they done in quartiles
allows you to see that every example in
figure two I don't believe there is an
exception to this no and I think also in
the in the other there's only one
exception to what I'm about to say sorry
two out of like God knows how many
they're all monotonically increasing and
decreasing in other words the dose
effect is always present another thing
is biologic plausibility you've spoken
at length about that today so in other
words sometimes you have to look at
epidemiology and ask is there a biologic
explanation and here there is you've
added another one which is evolutionary
conservation to the biologic
plausibility then you can talk about
animal models or experiments in humans
over short durations
that generally support these findings
and and so those are just a couple of
the the Bradford Hill criteria that that
lead to um you know my belief that yeah
there's reverse causality here but um
it's not the full explanation and that
more of the explanation is probably the
direction that's being proposed um and
if that's true because then at the end
of the day like what's the purpose of
the discussion the purpose of the
discussion is if you are under the
influence of any of these psychiatric
conditions in addition to the treatments
you're doing now what else can you do
and to me the takeaway is follow these
light behaviors I mean it's it's it's a
that's a relatively low lift when you
consider some of the other things like
I'm over here asking people to do Zone 2
for three hours a week and VO2 max
workouts and all this other stuff and
like I think all those things matter for
mental health as much as physical health
but this strikes me as on the spectrum
of low
asks if it shows if it's only even 30%
causality 70% reverse causality like
I'll take those I I would still instate
that yeah and it's you know it's taking
your coffee on the balcony it's and
people will often say well how do you do
this with kids the kids should be doing
it too right you know it means popping
your sunglasses off it means getting out
for just a few minutes and the fact that
it's additive that these you know these
Photon uh mechanis Photon counting
mechanisms they some is great and look
this paper also says and I should have
stated this earlier if you missed your
daytime light ration get your nighttime
dark ration they are independent and
additive so that's I mean that's a
really something um but of course
ideally you get both but I appreciate
your take on it and um you know and
thanks for for your uh expertise in
parsing epidemiology I look at fewer
studies of that of that sort but I
learned from you and um that's one of
the reasons I love doing these Journal
clubs as I learn so along those lines uh
tell us about the paper you selected I'm
really eager to learn more well I I
wanted to pick a paper that was you know
kind of interesting as a paper and and
this this paper I think is um
interesting in that it is kind of the
landmark study of a class of drugs but
in the same way that you kind of picked
a paper that I think has a much broader
overarching um importance the reason I
picked this paper which is um from the
New England Journal of Medicine it's
about 10 years old no correction 13
years
old is because it is kind of the
landmark study in a class of drugs that
I believe are the most relevant class of
drugs we've seen so far in cancer
therapy and even though the net effect
of these drugs has only served to reduce
mortality by maybe 8 to 10 per which is
not a huge amount um it's the manner in
which they've done it that gives me
great hope for the future even if it's
through other means so um I'll take a
step back before we go into the paper
for again just the context and
background
um so the human immune system is kind of
a remarkable thing uh it it's it's hard
when you're sort of trying to imagine
what's the most amazing part of the
human system and maybe it's my bias as
well because just as you spent you know
your time in the in the light system and
the in the photos sensing system I spent
my time in the Immunology world but it
is remarkable to me how our immune
systems evolved and they have this
really brutal task which is how can they
be
tuned to detect any foreign pathogen
that is harmful without knowing a
priority what that could be while at the
same so in other words how can you tune
a system to be so aggressive that it can
eradicate any virus or
bacteria billions of years into the
future without knowing what it's going
to
be but at the same time it has to be so
forgiving of the self that it doesn't
turn around and attack the self it's
remarkable and of course we can always
think of the Exceptions there are things
called autoimmune conditions so clearly
the system fails fails and the immune
system turns around and attacks the self
if you see a person with Vitiligo I have
a little bit of V Vitiligo on my back a
couple of spots clearly the immune
system is attacking something there and
destroying some of the pigment I didn't
realize viigo was autoimmune yeah um if
you know so there are lots of you know
more serious autoimmune conditions of
course you know somebody that has lupus
or you know where the immune system can
be attacking the kidney the immune
system can be attacking any autoimmune
conditions can be deadly but fortunately
they are very rare R and for the most
part this immune system works remarkably
well so how does it work and why is it
that cancer seems to evade it virtually
all of the time this is the question now
let's first of all talk about how it
works and then when I tell you how it
works you'll say that sounds amazing
clearly it should be able to destroy
cancer um I'm going to simplify it by
only talking about one system which is
how te- cells recognize and get
activated how te- cells recognize
antigens
so we have something called uh an
antigen so an antigen is an antibody
generating peptide so it's a it's a it's
a protein almost always a protein they
can be carbohydrates but they're almost
always proteins and they're very very
small peptides like we're talking as
little as nine amino acids maybe up to
20 amino acids so teeny tiny little
peptid
but it's amazing that in such a short
peptide the body can recognize if that's
Andrew or not Andrew I mean me again
think think about like we talk about
proteins in Kil adans right we're
talking about proteins in terms of
thousands of amino acids that make up
every protein in your body and yet if it
samples a protein and sees that hey this
little 9 10 15 peptide amino acid is not
part of you I know it's
and therefore I'm going to generate an
immune response to it so we have what
are called antigen presenting cells you
have cells that go around sampling
peptides and they will on these things
called MHC class receptors bring the
peptide up to the surface and serve it
up to the t- cell there are two types of
these there's MHC class one and MHC
Class 2 I only this is Major histo
compatibility comple that's
correct and um we refer to them that way
because they DET because of the context
in which they were discovered which was
for organ rejection so not surprisingly
when you need to put a kidney into
another person if that kidney is deemed
foreign it will not last long in the
early days of organ transplantation were
Rife with immediate rejections and by
not not I mean the immediates are the
incompatibilities but you know the
the sort of next layer of
incompatibility was MHC incompatibility
which would lead to you know within
within weeks the organ is gone as
opposed to within hours so you have
these two classes of MHC you have class
one and class two class one is what we
call
endogenous so this is basically what
happens when a protein or an antigen is
coming from inside the cell so let's
consider the flu so if you get the flu
the influen a virus infects the
respiratory epithelium of your uh you
know your larynx and that virus as you
know folks listening might remember from
our days of talking about covid viruses
can't replicate on their own what they
do is they hijack the replication um
Machinery of the host and they use that
either to insert their RNA or DNA to
replicate and in the process proteins
are being made well those proteins are
the proteins of the virus not of us so
some of those peptides get launched onto
these MH class MHC class one uh glove
basically the glove comes up to the
surface and a te- cell comes along and
in the case of MHC class one it's a cd8
t- cell these are what are called the
killer te- cells right and so this cell
comes along and with its t- cell
receptor the te- cell receptor meets the
MHC class one receptor with the antigen
in it and if that's a lock it realizes
that's my Target and it begins to
replicate and proliferate and Target
those and that creates the immune
response and by the way that's how it
works when you vaccinate somebody you're
basically pre-building that thing up so
would this fall under the Adaptive
immune response or the innate immune
response though this is adaptive yep
innate is just the pure antibody
response in the on the B cell side I
won't get into that for for for the
purpose of this discussion the other
example is MHC class two and that's also
part of the Adaptive system or the
innate system which uh is more what we
call the um exogenous form so these are
peptides that are usually coming from
outside the cell so we're going to focus
more on the MHC class one because this
is peptides that come from inside the
cell okay so just keep in the back of
your mind if a foreign protein gets
presented from inside a cell to outside
a cell the te- cells recognize that and
they will mount a foreign response and
by the way that's why we basically can
beat any virus like if you consider how
many viruses are around us the fact that
we almost never die from a viral
infection is a remarkable achievement of
how well this immune system works we're
constantly combating these viruses
constantly and by the way we don't
really have very effective antiviral
agents it's not like antibiotics like we
have antibiotics up to Wazoo I mean
we're way better at fighting viruses
than bacteria can I just one question
I've always wondered about this to what
is our ability to ward off viruses on a
day-to basis as an
adult reliant on us having been exposed
to that virus during development like
like as I walk around today maybe I'll
be exposed to 100, different viruses
would you say that half of those I've
already got antibodies too because I I
was exposed to them at some prior
portion of my life yeah hard quantify
and the other ones I'm just building up
antibodies like I was on I was on a
plane last night someone was coughing so
I was hiding I had Co a little while ago
so I wasn't too worried about that and I
feel great today but you
know I just assume that on that plane
I'm in a swamp of viruses no matter what
and that most of them I've already been
exposed to since I was a little kid so
I've got all the antibodies and they're
just fighting it back binding up those
viruses and and and destroying them yeah
I think it's part that and I also think
it's part of them that our body can
destroy without mounting much of an
immune response so therefore your immune
system is doing work and it's yet it's
not mounting a systemic inflammatory
response that you're not sensing so is
it also a physical trapping in you know
in my nasal epithelium it's a virus yeah
so so yeah let like there you have huge
barriers right so the skin you know the
hairs in your nose all of these things
are huge barriers but assuming that
still a bunch of them are getting in at
least the respiratory ones that's the
other thing to keep in mind right there
are certain viruses that are totally
useless floating around the air right
there are certain viruses you know the
viruses that most people are really
afraid of you know Hep C hepb HIV well
you know if they're sitting on a table
or floating around the air they're of no
threat to you they have to be you know
sort of transmitted through the barrier
um but again some of these viruses
you're going to defeat without an
enormous response and then some of them
you know like why is influenza quote
unquote such a bad virus whereas the
common respiratory cold kind of
Sidelines you for a day it's the immune
response that you're feeling the worse
the bigger the immune response to the
virus the more you're feeling that you
feel your immune system going crazy
right you know the in lucans that are
spiking the third spacing that occurs to
get more and more of the immune cells
there the spike of your temperature as
your body basically tries to cook the
virus all of that stuff is your body
yeah yeah you're being drained and all
this happening
so um one more point I'll mention just
but just to close the loop on the
autoimmunity um how is it that we learn
not to attack ourselves that's something
called thymic selection that occurs in
infancy so you and I have a no good for
nothing tiny little thymus that would be
it's almost impossible to see these
things you know when we used to operate
on people you know the thymus is barely
visible in an adult in a healthy adult
outside of thymic tumors but as a CH in
a child the thymus is quite large and
the purpose of the thymus is to educate
te- cells and basically show the te-
cells what self is
and any te- cell that doesn't
immediately recognize it gets killed so
it's it's a really clever system where
we basically teach you to recognize self
at a very early age and if you can't do
that you're weeded out and then the
thymus involutes thereafter because it's
sort of served its purpose okay now
let's talk about cancer so what do we
know about cancer so we know that again
you know cancer is a genetic disease in
the sense that every Cancer has genetic
mutations um most of those mutations are
sematic which means most of those
mutations are mutations that occur
during the course of our life they're
not germline mutations the germline
being the uh eggs and sperm right so
it's all other cells and I love that you
pointed out that you know there can be
gen that cancer can be genetic but isn't
necessarily inherited right people
genetic and they think inherited right
but inherited is always genetic to some
extent but um genetic isn't always
inherited yeah so there are a handful of
cancers that are uh derived from
inherited mutations so Lynch syndrome is
an example of that uh hereditary
polyposis is an example of that where
you have a gene that gets passed through
the germ line and that Gene codes for a
protein like all genes do and it's
either you have too much of a gene or
too little of of a gene so it's either a
gene that promotes cancer or and you
have too much of that or it's a gene
that prevents cancer and you have too
little of it or a dysfunctional version
of it right so braa is an example of
that braa is hereditary braa codes for a
protein and the the women and men but
mostly the women that we think about who
have a braa mutation that all in some
cases almost guarantees breast cancer
it's because of a defective copy so it's
like they don't get the protein that
they need to protect them from breast
cancer so what do we know well we know
that and this is probably one of the
most remarkable things I've ever learned
and it still blows my mind every time um
well actually before I get to that point
I want to make I want to make another
Point okay so so you might think so
cancer we we you know our cells become
cancerous but they're clearly hijacked
because they have these mutations and as
a result of these mutations they make
protein prots that allow cancers to
behave differently and Cancers behave
differently from non-cancer in two very
critical ways the first way is that they
do not respond to cell cycle signaling
so if you cut your skin it heals but how
does it know to heal just right and not
to keep growing and growing and growing
and growing and growing well it knows
that because there are cell cycle
signals that tell it time to grow time
to stop if believe it or not this is an
extreme example if you donated to me
half of your liver which I know you
would absolutely i' give you more than
half my you give if it meant that we
could keep doing these dral clubs right
um within months you would regenerate a
full liver that's so isn't that amazing
that's so wow it's like a salamander you
cut off a salamander Limb and please
don't do that experiment because other
people are doing it anyway and it grows
back and it knows how much to grow back
it's so wild so so when a cell is
perfectly functioning it knows how much
to grow and and it's well cancer loses
that ability that is one of the
Hallmarks of cancer it just keeps
growing it doesn't grow faster by the
way that's a misnomer people think
cancers grow faster than non-cancer
there's no real evidence that that's the
case they just don't stop growing the
second property of cancer is the
capacity to leave the site of origin go
someplace else and take up residence so
that's metastasis that's the metastasis
component so if you think about it for a
minute a cell that never stops
replicating and has the capacity to up
and leave and move and take up residence
is clearly different from the cell
itself right so if I have a cell of
colonic epithelium the cell that lines
the inside of my colon it's clearly got
a set of proteins in it but if all of a
sudden that thing can grow grow grow
grow grow not stop not stop not not
listen to the signal and then somehow
wind its way into the liver and just
keep growing and growing and growing it
must have different proteins so the
question question then becomes why does
cancer even exist how has our immune
system not figured out a way to just
silence this and eradicate it the way it
does to virtually every virus you
encounter and to me this is one of the
most interesting questions in all of
biology and it really comes down to how
clever cancer is unfortunately how
evolutionarily clever it is it basically
does a lot of things to trick the immune
system so it has its own secretory
factors that Tamp down the immune system
it grows in an environment because of
its nature so one of the things that's
long understood about cancer is it's
heavily glycolytic and when something is
heavily glycolytic it's going glucose to
pyruvate to lactate nonstop there are
lots of reasons for that um I think
there's more than one the what does that
afford it ises that a does that afford
it a migratory potential no so it's
super interesting so so that's the
effect what I just described is called
the warberg effect and when warberg
proposed this uh which God was probably
in the
1920s it was before World War I before
World War II um he proposed it be he
thought the mitochondria of cancer cells
were defective so he proposed that the
you know cancer cells mitochondria don't
work hence they have to undergo
glycolysis they can't undergo uh aerobic
um uh metabolism
um we now know that that's not the case
so we now know that the the the warberg
effect or the varberg effect if I'll
refer to him correctly by his name um
almost assuredly does not have to do
with defective mitochondria others have
proposed several mechanisms I think
there's probably more than one thing
going on so so so a paper that came out
in 2009 very influential paper um by a
guy named Matt vanderheiden and um Craig
Thompson and uh Luke kley proposed that
the reason that cancer cells do the
warberg effect is that they're not
optimizing for energy they're optimizing
for cellular building blocks and if you
do the mass balance it completely makes
sense like dividing cells need building
blocks more than energy and glycolysis
while very inefficient for generating
ATP is much more efficient at generating
substrate to make more cells but another
proposed mechanism is exactly at this
one glycolysis lowers the surrounding pH
because of lactate lactate attracts
hydrogen pH goes down and guess what
that does to the immune system detracts
the immune system so it's also a way to
hide from the immune system so there's a
like a pH cloaking use leveraging pH to
cloak the the signal that the immune
system would otherwise see yep and then
when you layer on top of that that it
knows how to secrete things like il10
TGF beta all of these other secretory
factors that also inhibit the immune
system basically it's figured out a way
to kind of hide itself from the immune
system the way you describe it can
sounds like a virus yes I mean it sounds
a lot like a virus and that leads me to
ask are there any examples of contagious
cancers I recall seeing some studies
about these little critters down in uh
uh Australia Tasmanian devils that like
they would uh they scratch each other in
fight as Tasmanian devils do they're
actually quite cute um and they would
get cancers and tumors growing on their
faces yes so so it and so it was it was
like it was like a literal physical
interaction that could transmit cancer
from one animal to the next so it's less
that there are viruses that cause cancer
so in that sense you could argue yes
there are contagious cancers well HPV
sure yeah HPV hepb uh hepc uh but but
there are even cancers like cutaneous
cancers that arise from viruses but um I
don't know if that's quite the same as
what you're saying like no no it's
they're both it what you're saying is an
important point I mean uh we don't want
to go down the the round a whole of of
HPV but right that's increasing
susceptibility to cervical cancer um now
there's a vaccine against HPV right
there wasn't when we were in college as
we all knew um there was no vaccine but
the um okay so but yeah direct
transmission of cancers from one one
organism to the next more rare yes okay
so now here a moment ago I said there's
this really incredible thing about
cancer that blows my mind and about our
immune system which is that at least 80%
of solid organ tumors and we're going to
mostly talk about solid organ tumors
because that's where the field of
oncology has made very little progress
so if you go back 50 years where has
oncology made huge progress it's made
great progress in uh blood tumors
leukemias and some kinds of lymphomas in
fact there's two kinds of lymphomas
where the progress has been remarkable
one has been in uh Hodgkins lymphoma and
the other has also been in immunotherapy
has been in a type of B cell lymphoma um
where that B cell demonstrates uh or
presents something called a cd19
receptor so in in in B cell lymphomas
with cd19 imuno there's a very unique
Niche immunotherapy we won't talk about
that today called car therapy that has
got rid of those guys and then leukemias
have also been pretty good but in solid
organ
tumors there have been only two real
breakthroughs in the last 50 years one
has been the therapy for a certain type
of IC cancer um and it's really just a
chemotherapy cocktail that has been
found to work really well and the other
has been in this really rare kind of
gastric cancer called The Gist stromal
tumor which happens to result from one
mutation in a kise pathway and there's
one drug that can now Target that and it
works it's kind of amazing cures that
cancer cures that what I'm talking about
are the cancers that kill virtually
everybody else this is what when you
sort of line up what are the big causes
of cancer death
let's start at the top it's lung it's
then breast and prostate in men and
women it's coloral it's pancreas those
are the big five they kill more than 50%
of Americans it cancer- wise not sorry
let me restate that more than 50% of
cancer deaths in Americans come from
those five these are what we call the
solid epithelial tumors and you can
March down the list and most cancers
that most people are thinking of are
those cancers well here's the thing more
than 80% of those
cancers have antigens that are
recognized by the host's immune system I
will state it again because it is so
profound 80% at least of those cancers
actually generate an antigen meaning a
little peptide in that cell gets
presented to the te- cell and it is
recognizable and now the question is why
is that not sufficient to induce
remission and the short answer is
there are not enough te- cells that are
able to act and or they are being
sufficiently inhibited from acting which
gets me to the point of this paper one
of the ways in which the body inhibits
the immune system which we should remind
ourselves is an important thing right is
something called the checkpoint
inhibitor okay so go back to that idea
that I talked about before you have an
antigen presenting cell it brings up an
MHC receptor with a peptide on it and
there is a t- cell that is coming and I
actually brought a diagram which we're
going to I'm going to link to this CU I
I don't want to make this too
complicated but I really think that this
figure is helpful to understand how
these papers uh how these drugs work so
the MHC receptor with the peptide is
sitting there and it binds to the T t-
Cell receptor on the t- cell but there
is another receptor on the t- cell a
ctla4
receptor and that binds to a receptor
that I won't bother naming now because
it's the the the names don't matter but
there's another receptor on the antigen
presenting cell that binds to that and
that acts as the breaks in the reaction
so
ctla4 which is on the t- cell binds to
another CD receptor on the antigen
presenting cell and it says Tamp down
the
response and the reason for that is we
want to keep our immune system in check
this basically is a way of asking the
immune system because remember when the
immune system sees that antigen it wants
to go nuts it wants to start replicating
and killing that this is a cd8 cell it
is a targeted killer t- cell the
checkpoint says let's double check that
let's be sure let's Tamp down the
response and as a result of that a
thought experiment emerged which was
what if we block
ctla4 what if we block the checkpoint
could we unleash the immune system a
little bit more and I will say this at
the time it was proposed it seemed a bit
far-fetched
um because of the complexity of the
immune system it seemed a little
far-fetched that simply blocking the
checkpoint would have any
effect it's also worth noting that prior
to this one immunotherapy had found some
efficacy which was trying the exact
opposite strategy rather than blocking
the inhibitor it was throwing more
accelerant at the fire which was giving
something called inter Lucin 2 so
interlukin 2 is for lack of a better
word candy and fuel for te- cells so the
idea was if we have te- cells that
innately recognize a cancer antigen can
we just give high doses of interlukin 2
and have them undergo proliferation and
response and the answer turned out to be
yes but only in two cancers melanoma and
kidney cancer and only at very small
levels about 10% of the population would
respond to these things now look that's
10% of people who were going to be dead
within 6 months because these are
devastating Cancers and once they spread
there are no treatments that have any
efficacy whatsoever in fact I think
media and survival for metast melanom at
the time was probably 4 months so this
was a very Grim death sentence um but
the idea now was what about doing the
exact opposite approach instead of
trying to throw more uh fire at the t-
cell what if we can take its breaks down
less gas pardon me instead of giving
more gas let's give less
breaks and um there were some phase two
some phase one studies that demonstrated
efficacy phase two and the paper I'm
going to talk about today is the is the
phase three uh uh U study that compared
um the first version of these so so the
the drug we're going to talk about today
is an anti-la 4 drug called um
iolab um there is another drug out there
that came came along shortly thereafter
that is um an anti- pd1 drug so
pd1 uh turns out to be another one of
these checkpoints on te- cells and the
Nobel Prize by the way I think it was
2018 or 2019 in medicine or physiology
was actually awarded to The two
scientists who discovered ctla4 and pd1
so you know this I believe this is the
only Nobel Prize in medicine for
immunotherapy it's a very big
deal so this study um sought to compare
the effect of antict 4 to a placebo and
the placebo in this case was not a real
Placebo it was a peptide vaccine called
GP100 um to ask the question in patients
with metastatic melanoma what would be
the impact on median survival and
overall survival so um let's talk a
little bit about the paper so again one
of the funny things about this is um I
used to read these papers a lot Andrew
these these used to be these used to be
my bread and butter papers so I I mean
you know be you know reading these like
I'm you
know it's my hobby and and I don't read
them that much anymore so it was kind of
amazing how long it took me to remind
myself of stuff I used to remember but
you do have to kind of go back and read
the methods and figure out who were the
patients in this what was the
eligibility criteria why did they do it
this way and of course it all kind of
came back to me but um it it took a
minute so so so the first thing is these
are all patients who um had progressed
through every standard therapy so these
are patients for whom there were no
other options um these patients either
had very Advanced stage three melanoma
which means it was local Regional
melanoma but it couldn't be reected so
an example of that would be um a cancer
that was you know completely engulfing
like where let's say the primary site
was the cheek and it had completely
grown into all of the surrounding soft
tissue it hadn't spread anywhere but it
was you know all the lymph nodes of the
neck um and and I've seen patients like
this and it's you know it's just
completely
disfiguring um and they'd already been
through the standard chemotherapy and
nothing was working and the thing was
growing and then it was mostly made up
of patients with stage four cancer now
melanoma has a very funny staging system
so in cancer we typically talk about
something called the tnm staging system
it is the standard way that cancers are
staged T refers to the tumor size n
refers to the lymph node status and M
refers to the presence or absence of
metastases and for most cancers it is a
very simple system it is you know T is
typically a number one two sometimes up
to three and four n is typically 0 1 or
two and M is z or 1 either there's no
Mets or there are Mets so for example in
coloral cancer um the T staging
determines the depth in the colon wall
that it went n is did it go to Mets and
I think in Colon I'm a little rusty on
this I think colon has n01 or two
depending on how many lymph nodes and
then m0 did it go to anything beyond
that like to the liver lung Etc or not
melanoma is a bit more complicated it
has m0 meaning no Mets but it also has
M1 a m1b m1c C and
m1d and within each of those it has a
threshold for high and low lactate
dehydrogenase or LDH so it's both a
staging based on Imaging and biochemical
and the reason for that is LDH level is
such a strong prognostic indicator of
survival in addition to M staging uh
higher LDH levels tend to reflect more
acidity which we talked about why that's
problematic tends to reflect faster
growing tumors higher turnover higher
metabolic
activity M1A let me see if I can
remember this
m1as are Cancers that have
metastasized
to um surrounding soft tissue or soft
tissue anywhere in the body so anywhere
else on the skin and you might think
well that's kind of crazy like how does
that happen and it's really bizarre you
can have a patient who had a melanoma
that showed up in one part of their body
and then they have metastases on other
parts of their skin m1b B is uh and I
always get B and C confused I think B is
the lung so m1b is to the lung m1c is to
any internal organ so liver Etc and m1d
is to the CNS and as those numbers
increase as those letters increase the
prognosis gets lower and lower and lower
so one of the first things I always look
at when I look at a paper like this is
tell me about the patient population
like what what was the um you know what
was the breakdown of patients and in
table one so that's again in clinical
papers like this table one is always
always always Baseline
characteristics um oh I should mention
one other thing Andrew this was done as
a 3: one: one
randomization so again in the simplest
form a study would have two groups right
you would have um we're going to just
have a treatment group and a placebo
group but in this arm you had three
groups with one of them being the place
Placebo the placebo got just GP 100
which is just a cancer vaccine by the
way this is a cancer vaccine that never
showed any efficacy so it was a cancer
vaccine that had been tested both with
interlukin 2 directly and um as an adant
for patients who had metastatic melanoma
or had sorry not metastatic melanoma who
had melanoma reected who were tumor free
and then given the vaccine as adant to
see did that have an effect on outcomes
and it didn't so it's kind of a known
Placebo so you had that group then you
had the antict 4 group and then you had
antict 4 plus GP 100 yeah what's the
rationale for the 3:1: one it's
basically it increases statistical power
right so you know this total study was a
little under 700 people they put 400 in
the anti-la 4 plus gp1 100 group and
then you you know little over 130 in
each of the other two groups so you're
always going to be able to make these
two comparisons right what you can check
by doing this is is there any effective
GP 100 in this setting which had never
been done before so again GP 100 is a
known protein expressed by
melanoma and all of these people were
haplotyped to make sure that their
immune system would recognize it and the
question was would giving people
anti C4 I.E taking the breaks off their
immune system with or without gp00 make
a difference so kind of going through
this you can see it sort of skews about
60% to 40% male to female they talk
about something called the ecog
performance status that refers to how
healthy a patient is coming in so ecog
zero is no limitations whatsoever which
is kind of amazing when you really
consider something I think this speaks
to just how devastating this disease is
um these are patients who all have like
6 months to live right you know a year
Max and yet look at this 58 to 60% of
them have no limitation on their quality
of life at this very moment that's going
to change dramatically um you know
absent a cure here and then ecog 1 has
some limitation and you can see that EOG
1 plus ecog 0 is basically 98% of the
population you can see the staging there
so again very very few of these patients
are the m0 category zeros are people who
have stage three disease that is so
aggressive it can't be reected that's
about 1% but the majority of these
people are the m1as M1 BS M1 C's so
these are people with very aggressive
cancers you can also see that about 10
to 15% of these people also have CNS
metastases again the poorest prognosis
of the poor and then you can see the uh
about 40% of them have the LDH level
above above cut off all of this is to
say we're talking about a group of
patients who have um you know a very
high likelihood of not
surviving more than you know a year it
would be very you know unlikely that
that many of these patients would
survive more than a year so so basically
More than 70% of these people have
visceral metastasis uh a third have high
LDH and 10 more than 10% have brain Mets
they've also all progressed through
standard therapy so um radiation chemo
yeah and the chemo for for for melanoma
can be you know kind of a toxic chemo
that that really just doesn't really do
anything so is it common place to use a
treatment that failed in clinical trials
as a placebo in these sorts of studies
yeah it's interesting I I think you're
referring obviously to the GP 100 and I
think the thing thinking
was okay it hasn't been effective in
other treatments for example when
combined with I2 or as an adant but
never before has it been tried with a
checkpoint inhibitor which is the
technical term for this type of
drug um I think there was also some
belief that it would be easier to enroll
patients I don't think they stated this
but that's often the case it would be
easier to enroll patients if they would
know that even in the placebo arm
they're still getting an active agent
got it and I suppose there's always the
possibility that the combination of the
uh failed drug with a new drug would
work and then so you're increasing the
probability for novel Discovery for sure
and again if you go back to the
randomization of 3 to one: one it's
really only 1 or 20% of the participants
that would get just the GP 100 so in
other words you're basically telling
people when they come into this study
there's an 80% chance you're going to
get antict 4 that's a much better set of
odds than you know your typical study
where you're going to be 50% likely to
get the uh agent of Interest right and
people who are
literally dying of cancer that they W
they don't want to be in the control
group right that's right so the primary
outcome for this study actually changed
in the study now they have to get
permission to do that um but the so the
original primary end point was the best
overall response rate so I have to
explain how response rates are measured
this is this is a bit complicated
remember all of these patients by
definition have measurable visible
cancer by visible either on the surface
of their body but more likely on an MRI
or CT scan so all of these patients had
to be scanned head totoe within 12 weeks
of enrollment um again there's another
thing I should point out here which I
know you understand but it's always
worth finding people when a study like
this takes place it usually takes place
over many years and so it's not the case
that all 700 of these patients were
enrolled on the same day and finished
you know we finished observing them on
the same day no no no this took place
for a very long period of time this took
place across tens of centers uh I can't
remember if this was just globally or
across the world it might have been
across the world um and so every Center
really needs to adhere to a very strict
protocol and you have a central organiz
ation that is running this so you have a
drug company I think this is brist
Bristol Meers squib that makes the drug
they provide the drug and then you have
a cro a clinical research organization
that that is basically managing the
trial and the trial is being done at
Cancer Centers all over the world or all
over the country and you know enrollment
I think began in 2008 for this no no I
think it completed in 2008 it probably
started in about 2004 2005 and and
therefore you had to kind of have real
clear protocols around this so a
complete response is the easier of these
to understand a complete response is
everything vanishes
completely that's very rare in cancer
therapy so instead what we kind of look
for is a partial response a partial
response and there is really different
ways to Define this there are different
criteria but this is the most common way
you define a partial response a partial
response is at least a
50% reduction by diameter because
remember in this type Imaging you're
looking at 2D versus 3D so if you're
looking at a lung lesion and it's this
big it you know if it's 2 centimeters
long it has to go to at least 1
centimeter in diameter so it's a 50%
reduction at least of every single
lesion with no new lesions appearing and
no lesions growing so it's very strict
criteria right again CR means everything
vanishes PR means at least a 50% by
diameter which by the way is a much
bigger diameter much bigger reduction in
terms of tumor volume when you consider
the linear versus the third power
relationship of length and volume of
every single lesion with nothing new
appearing regardless of how small and no
lesion growing so that's a PR so you
basically have no
response
progression we talk about those together
and then partial response and complete
response so initially the the authors of
this study were going to the primary end
point of this was going to be the best
overall response rate so what was the
proportion of patients that hit PR what
was the proportion that hit a CR um
that's very common in this type of paper
where the outcomes are typically so dire
um however uh oh I think I said I think
I said that the study was um I I don't
remember when the study ended but the
amendment was made to change the primary
endpoint to overall
survival
um at some point during the study so and
by the way that tends to be the metric
everybody cares most about so the
overall survival for metastatic melanoma
is zero um with the exception of people
who respond to interlukin 2 high do
interlukin 2 and that will boost the
overall survival rate to somewhere
between 8 and
10% very very low these patients many of
whom had already taken and progressed
through interlukin 2 Let me refresh my
memory on what percentage of those
patients about a quarter of these
patients had already taken high dose
interlukin 2 and by definition the fact
that they're in this study means they
had already progressed through that that
treatment had failed just reiterate um
just kind of the state these patients
are in so now let's look at figure one
so again I'll describe it because I
realize many people are just listening
to us all of this will be available both
in the video and then we'll link to the
paper so figure one is a a figure that
probably looks really familiar to people
who look at you know any data that deal
with survival it's called a Kaplan Meyer
survival curve so on the xaxis for this
curve is time
and time here is shown in months and on
the Y AIS is the overall survival at the
very top 100% at the bottom
0% and it has three graphs or three
curves that are superimposed on one
another for each of the three groups
again the control group which is the GP
100 the um anti-la 4 Group by itself and
the ntla 4 plus GP 100 and one of the
characteristics of a Kaplan Meyer curve
is by definition they have to be
decreasing in a monotonic fashion
because it's cumulative overall survival
that just means it can't like come down
and go back up nobody comes back to life
so once a person dies they are censored
from the study and the curve drops and
drops and drops and you can see that
they kind of highlight and I actually
think it makes the graph a little harder
to read when they when they put some of
those marks on there but what really
becomes clear when you look at this is
is that there's a key there's a clear
distinction between the curve for the
placebo group the gp00 group and the
other two the two treatment groups now
you'll note at the very end that the two
treatment groups appear to separate a
little bit I'll talk about that in a
second so when I look at these Andrew I
the first thing I always turned my
attention to I can't resist I have to
look at the right hand side of the graph
cuz what is that really telling me right
that the tale of this is showing me the
true overall
survival and I want to sort of figure
out what is going on so in the GP 100
Group which is the placebo group it is
kind of amazing to think that there is
still one person who is alive at 44
months it's it's amazing I mean it's
both sobering and amazing that like one
person made it to 44 months um the next
thing I ask myself is well how long did
half of the people make it that's called
median survival and to do that you go up
to the Y AIS and you draw a little line
from the 50 over and then you bring that
down and and that's you know that's
that's that's awfully low that's about
yeah in fact the table will tell us
exactly what that is because I think
it's really hard to eyeball that stuff
so let's go to so there's always a table
that will accompany these things and
let's pull up that table I've got this
paper spread out over so many things
let's Adverse Events where's our
survival table here figure two subgroup
analysis of overall
survival it would probably be helpful if
I stapled these things together because
it would be EAS well this is always a
trade-off actually for since this is a
journal Club episode I I will say that
stapling helps but it also prevents one
from separating things out writing in
the margin I like these little mini
clips no Financial relationship to the
mini clips either um just have to state
that cuz I always get if you don't say
that people go oh you must have a steak
in these mini clips I like these little
mini clips in fact I'm such a nerd I
always have one of these uh pilot V5 v7s
in my Pock on my pocket of my hip and
then my pockets are always filled with
um with these little mini clips and um
but then again I have a friend who's a
musician he's and he's always reigning
guitar picks so you know it's an as far
as occupational hazards go of being a
nerd I'm a big fan of the mini clip as
well but I I went without it today all
right so thank you yes table two all
right so so let's look at table two
while looking at the Kaplan Meer curve
because now this allows us to see a
couple things by the way remember how I
said there's like that one person who
kind of is still alive in the treatment
group well you can tell that he's not a
complete responder he or she is not a
complete responder because um under
evaluation of therapy in table two it
says best overall response and it says
complete responders zero so there was
Zero complete responders in the placebo
there were two partial responders again
a partial responder is um some lesions
got smaller some got bigger stable
disease is it didn't really change that
much and Progressive disease is
obviously it went beyond not when you
say partial response like lesions got
smaller are they literally just tracing
the the circumference of one of these
you know skin lesions and saying okay
got bigger smaller you literally we' had
rulers iny yep yep feels this feels so
crude in terms of like like I mean it
makes total sense but like in terms of
like modern medicine oh like your lesion
Grew From like 3 millimeters to 6 millim
and that we literally like drawing
little boundaries around little blotches
on the skin yeah you're you're putting a
little measuring tape on them now again
most of these are happening in the
Radiology Suite because most of the
disease for these patients is inside the
body body remember More than 70% of
these patients had visceral metastases
so liver soft tissue uh lung brain you
know these are in fact if you include
lung liver brain and viscera it's it's
all the pretty much all the patients so
most of this is looking at a CT scan or
an MRI for the brain got it um okay so
that's that's kind of the first thing
that comes up the median response rate
should should be shown pretty
prominently here so I'm looking through
through this
and where is median
response maybe it's shown in a different
table uh let's
see not Disease Control rate time to
[Music]
progression I remember it's about 10
months but maybe that's just in the
text yeah here it is so I thought this
would be in a table but it's uh it's on
page 75 of the paper it just reports it
so and I'm sorry I misspoke um the 10
months was for the antict 4 plus
gp00 and 6.4 months for the GP100 alone
that's the control and then 10.1 for the
ntla 4 alone okay so again I always and
again I'm just always doing this I'm
kind of going back to the paper to be
like does that make sense and yeah you
kind of called it right you said median
survival was about eight well it turns
out it's actually like six and change
because cuz it has that little ding in
it and it's out to a little past 10 on
the two others so the net takeaway here
is again just to put that in English
because it's so
profound 50% of the patients in the
control group were dead in 6
months 50% of the patients in the
treatment group both treatment groups
were dead in 10 months so what that
means in cancer speak is
these drugs extended median Survival by
four
months now that's a that's an important
concept you know when we think about how
has cancer therapy changed over the past
50 years median survival for metastatic
cancer has increased across the board so
a person today with metastatic coloral
cancer or woman today with metastatic
breast cancer or a person with
metastatic lung cancer these people will
live longer with those diseases today
thanks mostly to treatments this is not
an early detection lead time bias issue
this is treatments are allowing people
to live longer and that's an important
part of the story but it's only half of
the story yet it often gets touted as
the story the other half of the story
and frankly the story that I think is
more important is what is overall
survival doing and if you go back to
those answers the answer is
zero so overall survival hasn't changed
for solid epithelial tumors it is it was
0% in 1970 and it's 0% today everyone
dies everyone dies from metastatic solid
organ tumors now again there's those
there's those Niche examples I gave you
testicular cancer is now an exception um
gomal tumors would be an exception and
I'm not including leukemia and lymph FAS
where now there are exceptions okay
within not to try and be overly
optimistic but if I look at the graph in
figure one and I look out at the tail of
the graph that's right um and for those
that are just listening what I see and
and I'm far less far less familiar with
this type of work and this analyzing
these type of data but what I see is
that people in the placebo group They're
All Dead except that one Yep they're
basically all dead at 44 months y but
when I look at the number how long it
takes for everyone to be dead in the
true treatment groups it's like 50 looks
like 53 54 months or so well and they're
and they're not dead that's the point
they're hanging in there right so
because you know an extra somebody who
um lost both of my uh scientific
advisers two of the three the other one
to Suicide we've talked about this
before but the other uh two to different
cancer both had the bracka 2 mutation by
the way um you know an extra 8 to 10
months with your kids or with your
spouse or to quote unquote get your
Affairs in order is is a big deal I mean
it's still depressing in the sense that
nobody survives long term but um you
know an extra 10 months as long as one
is not miserable in that time completely
miserable um I mean that's e extra 10
months of living right well and and
what's interesting here is you know the
observation period stops and some of
these patients are still going so what
you're highlighting is kind of the point
I want to make which is overall survival
is the most important metric and it's
the highest bar make no mistake about it
and it's certainly not the bar any drug
company is ever going to want to talk
about for a cancer drug but why not
because because they don't none of them
work right like we don't have you know
like drug they only want to talk about
cures they don't want to talk they only
want to talk about media and survival
they want they only want to talk about
extending media in survival and you know
there are you know lots of people out
there that are on this on this platform
I don't need to get on to it but who
will say like look it's a real racket in
in oncology today where drugs that are
extending median Survival by four weeks
are being put on the market at a tune of
you know $50 to $100,000 per treatment
that's not uncommon in oncology uh there
was one drug that was approved for
pancreatic cancer I believe it extended
median Survival by days and it cost
$40,000 and it's being advertised as
significant extens because it was that
was a statistical significant
Improvement in media and survival I'm
just yeah so it's look it's really
understandable why people are very
skeptical of the Pharma industry and and
I think you know a much more nuanced
view is necessary clearly I don't think
Pharma is all bad um but I really
understand why people lose faith in
Pharma when when you know these types of
products somehow make regulatory
approval does insurance cover these
kinds of drugs uh it can in fact it
often does it depends on the FDA
approval of course and the indication um
but a lot of times they do right so yeah
there's a societal cost to these things
um but but there's also a patient cost
right so a lot of times insurance
doesn't fully cover it and a patient has
to Bear the the cost difference and on
top of that you alluded to this a second
ago which is what if your quality of
life is dramatically compromised as a
result of this treatment and yes
statistically you're going to live 9
days longer or 3 weeks longer but at
what cost to your health in those final
remaining days and by the way you're
potentially straddling your loved ones
with enormous debt uh in your absence so
it's it's a super complicated topic yeah
there's a dignity component too I mean
I've seen this in people dying you know
at some point they become such a a
diminished version of their former
selves that they don't want to be seen
by people that way so what is exciting
about this drug although it's this paper
is not the one that shows it the reason
I chose this paper Andrew is because it
was the first approval a second drug
came along that is an anti- pd1 drug
that drug is called Kuda that drug
turned out to be even better and had has
even a greater response rate both in
terms of median survival and overall
survival but this was the landmark paper
I also have slight bias here and I'll
disclose in a moment why um but I but I
think it just talks about very
interesting biology so let's talk about
a couple things that stuck stuck out to
me in this paper um the first thing that
stuck out to me and the authors didn't
comment on it unless they did and I
missed it is look at figure two so
figure two is the um subgroup analyses
where you're sort of showing a similar
graph to the one you showed earlier
right where you you show the response
rate or the change in response between
the groups and then you put the error
bars on it and this is where we talk
about how well it's a 95% confidence
interval so does it touch the unity line
so these are called like tornado plots
typically and um what you'll notice is
that in the top you're looking at um um
sort of uh it's it's comparing the
antict 4 with GP100 versus the gp1 100
and in the bottom you're looking at the
anti ca4 versus the GP 100 so at a
glance you can see GP 100 is not doing
anything I mean that's the that's the
first takeaway of comparing A to B um
what I find most interesting is look at
the subgroup analysis of
females notice that in females while
there's a trend towards risk reduction
and this is risk reduction for overall
mortality so again I just want to
restate that the primary outcome of this
trial was changed to overall survival
which I think is the better outcome by
the way and overall for all patients in
when you compare antict 4 plus Placebo
versus placebo there was a
31% risk reduction in overall mortality
that's what that's that's the
mathematical interpretation of what
you're seeing at the tail end of that
Kaplan Meyer curve longer living longer
and it's a it sounds like a big
difference and in some some sense it is
a big difference it is for those people
because you're really looking at
basically 0% surviving in the placebo
group versus 20% of people are still
alive at 56 months in the treatment
group but look that means 80% have died
right um but notice that and and and and
sori when you just look at the antict a
4 plus GP 100 in the subgroup B that
Hazard ratio is even showing more
compression it's a 36% reduction in risk
of death um but notice that the females
did not reach significance so in the in
the first group they barely do and you
can see that because the confidence
interval runs from 0.55 to 0.92 and
notice the error bar almost touches the
line and in the second one it does not
reach significance at all
so I actually went and kind of did a
little reading on this after and I said
hey you know how much did this study was
this an outlier study and it turned out
it wasn't um and that about half the
studies of antict 4 did indeed find that
the drug was less effective in women
than men which I found interesting now I
couldn't find any great explanation for
it but the most plausible explanations
fit into two categories the first are
maybe there are differences in the
immune response to the drug if you're a
man or a woman the second uh comes down
to dosing I should have said this at the
outset but of course these drugs are not
like a pill where it's like everybody
gets you know 50 milligrams of this
they're all dosed based on weight so
this study is dosed I believe at 3
milligrams per kilogram and because most
men are heavier than women men are
getting a higher dose than
women and weight and body surface area
an immune system like these things are
not all perfectly linear so I I I kind
of wonder if this difference is simply
explained by men on average getting a
higher dose than women
interesting last thing I want to talk
about here is in table
three so Table Three always an important
table to look at in any paper is what
are the
adverse outcomes right what are the
adverse effects of the drug yeah I spent
some I spent a little bit of time with
this and I I confess it it you know I
definitely don't want cancer to the
extent that I can avoid it but this
table made me wonder whether or not I
would also want to just avoid cancer
treatment given the life extension
provided I mean these Adverse Events are
pretty uncomfortable they sound just to
put just to put in perspective um and
you always have to kind of you know be
mindful of how many of these adverse
events are occurring in people just
because their disease is progressing so
the first thing I always want to look at
is total Adverse Events in all three
groups not just grade so grade three and
grade four are real toxicities right
grade four toxicity is life-threatening
toxicity by the way uh grade three is
pretty significant toxicity grade one
and two we typically just you know
that's not that severe right the little
rash put some cortico steroids on it it
went away kind of thing okay so in the
uh treatment plus GP 100 group 98 8.4%
of people reported some event so all but
1.6% in the ntct 4 group alone it was
96.7% so only 3.1% did not but in the
placebo group it's 97% so it's important
to keep in mind like you know
everybody's having some adverse effect
okay well what if you say well let's
just limit it to the most severe events
well let's just talk about grade four
toxicities there were 6.1% of those in
the placebo group
8.4% in the anti ca4 group and
6.8% in the combined group so not a huge
difference in grade four toxicity
meaning that whatever adverse events are
occurring may not be related to they may
not be related to the treatment the
again these are if you if you think
about it and it's a very awful sad
morbid thought to imagine these are
you're looking at the adverse responses
of people more than 80% of whom died
during the course of a very very short
study and so you know it's very
difficult to disentangle what effects or
what side effects a person is having
just from that process uh as they are
from the actual treatment but if there
is an area where there's a really clear
difference it's down in the autoimmune
category so if you look at any immune
related events you can see that in the
anti C4 plus gp1 100 group it's about
60%
in both of those treatment groups versus
30% and if you look at the grade three
and four toxicities it's 10% in the uh
antict 4
15% in the um antict 4 alone group and
only 3% in the treatment so that's a
real difference well it makes sense that
people getting this
drug plus Placebo or just the drug would
have autoimmune issues because this is
an immunotherapy it's an immunomodulator
in fact what is it doing it is taking
the breakes off the immune system but
then again the things that they list
out puitis is that a irritation of the
skin yeah irritation of the skin I'm not
a physician but I know that any itis is
going to be like an inflammation and
unfortunately likely a cancer or cell
replication look at the difference in
viigo I mean
um wow yeah so very or sorry sorry look
at the gastro intestinal differences
yeah and the Vitiligo right so 3.7% 2.3%
8% the GI stuff is the most common stuff
you're going to see there those are
those are the really big ones now and of
course there's diarrhea and there's
diarrhea oh like there's traveler
diarrhea
there's overly spicy large me4 diarrhea
and then there's like can't really do
anything besides make trips back and
forth to the bathroom di well there's
there's there's put it this way there's
you know colitis here is diarrhea so
significant these patients require ire
IV fluids now what what you don't see
here is how many of these patients
actually required corticosteroids to
reverse the autoimmunity so a lot of
times what will happen here in these
studies or with these drugs is the
autoimmunity becomes so significant that
you have to stop the drug and give
cortico steroids do the exact opposite
you now have to shut the immune system
down so you just took the brakes off it
with the drug and now you need to shut
it down with
corticosteroids
um when I was was I in med school no
when I was in my uh Fellowship um I
wrote a paper about um autoimmunity
correlating with response rate in ncta 4
uh early on this was during the phase
two work so you so the NCI was a very
early um uh uh adopter of U
participating in these trials and um you
know it was observed that or at least
hypothesize this is what the paper
basically wrote about which was is there
any correlation between autoimmunity and
response um and it turned out the answer
was yes there was a very strong
correlation so there was no difference
in autoimmunity between the doses and
the so the paper we wrote was two dosing
schedules so it was basically the full
dose the three milligrams per kilogram
versus a low dose 1 milligram per
kilogram this is a phase two trial those
are your two arms they're turned out to
no difference in autoimmunity between
them but there was a big difference
between um uh the response rate that
tied to autoimmunity in other words
autoimmunity predicted response now I
think over time these U investigators
the doctors who administer these
treatments are getting better and better
at catching these things earlier because
these autoimmune conditions uh can
actually be devastating so on a very
personal note when k truda uh came out I
want to say it was around
200 11 no no no gosh it must have been
2013 2014 thereabouts um again it was
for treatment of metastatic melanoma I
want to come back and explain why
melanoma gets all of the attention in
autoimmune condition in in um um
immunotherapy conditions I'll state that
but um but anyway a friend of mine got
pancreatic cancer and he got um the bad
type of pancreatic cancer so this is uh
an like the um um adenocarcinoma in the
pancreas right so this this is a a
non-survivable type of cancer
furthermore his was
unresectable so can you explain what
that is yeah so the only so about 20% of
people who have pancreatic cancer
technically have it in a way where you
could still take out the head of the
pancreas right the Whipple procedure the
Whipple procedure um now tragically most
of those patients will still recur my
understanding it is that pancreatic
cancer progresses from anterior to
posterior in the pancreas and that the
Whipple is a removal of the front end
the anterior that's the Whipple
procedure so if the cancer has
progressed far enough coddle into the
posterior uh pancreas then there's
nothing left to cut out basically um can
we survive without a pancreas for any
amount of time oh yeah absolutely so why
don't they just remove the whole
pancreas oh that's my point it's already
microm metastized so it's not the the
surgical procedure is not the challenge
anymore it used to be so you know at
John's Hopkins which is one of the
hospitals where this was pioneered like
the the 30-day mortality for a Whipple
procedure was I don't know
80% and the reason was to figure out how
to suture a pancreas to the bowel
without the so so the pancreas is such
an awful organ to operate on because its
enzyme are designed to digest anything
and everything so imagine now you have
to cut the pancreas in half take out the
head of the pancreas with the duodenum
and then somehow sew that open half of a
raw pancreas to the end of the junam and
not let it digest itself someone at
Hopkins figure this out um now the first
one was actually done by AO Whipple but
yes at Hopkins is where they figured out
the way to put drains in the surgical
technique how to do it in two layers
what type of stitches to use like all of
the nuances of this were worked out in a
few places but I would say Hopkins more
than any place else and are there
Physicians who like try this on
non-human primates or something or is
this always just done on patients and
you well nowadays I mean put it this way
even 25 years ago at a at a at a major
Center like Hopkins the the mortality of
that procedure was less than 1% amazing
yeah have been some vict
well yes but here's my point it that
that's no longer the bottleneck right
taking out the pancreas safely as
complicated and challenging as that is
and if you need a whip procedure you
only want to have it done by someone who
just does that night and day because
it's you don't want Weekend Warriors
doing it um that's not why people are
living or dying they're dying because
the pan the cancer just comes back it
was already spread to the liver by the
time you did it you just didn't realize
it yet so whether you took out the whole
pancreas or the head of the pancreas or
the tail of the pancreas the location of
the
tumor is predictive of survival only in
the extent that it basically is a window
into how soon did symptoms occur so
pancreatic cancers in the tail tend to
be more fatal even though they're way
easier surgically to take out because by
the time you develop symptoms of a tail
pancreas cancer it's it's a big cancer
so I was going to ask this question lat
later but I'll just ask it now given the
link between the immune system and these
cancers is there an idea in mind that
people who are let's say 40 and older or
50 and older who don't yet they're not
diagnosed with any cancer would
periodically just stimulate their immune
system to wipe out whatever early
cancers might be cropping up you know
just take a drug to just ramp up the
immune system even to the point where
you're start having a little diarrhea
maybe a few skin rashes and then come
off the drug you know just basically to
to fight back whatever little cell
growths are starting to take place in
skin or liver you know maybe for you
know three weeks out of each year I mean
why not yeah that's an interesting
question um I've never thought of it
through that lens I suppose the question
is what can we do to keep our immune
systems as healthy as possible as we age
because stay on a normal circadian
schedule there's evidence for that sure
no there's evidence that certainly if it
promotes sleep anything that promotes
better rest is going to promote immune
Health um because if you ask the macro
question which is like why does the
prevalence of cancer increase so
dramatically with age um there are
certain diseases where it's really
obvious why the prevalence of the
disease increases with age yeah like mac
like uh age related macular degeneration
sure or cardiovascular disease is by far
the most obvious because it's an area
under the curve exposure problem the
more exposure to lipoproteins and the
more the endothelium gets damaged the
more likely you are to accumulate plaque
and again it totally makes sense why
10year olds don't have heart attacks and
80y olds
do but when you sort of acknowledge that
well hey you know can't you know
anybody's Accu accumulating genetic
mutations we're always surrounded and
being bombarded by things that are
altering the Genome of our cell is it
simply a stochastic process where the
longer you live the more of these
mutations are going to occur until at
some point one of them just wins I I I
think that's got to be a big part of it
but I think another part of it and I
clearly I'm not alone in thinking this
is that our immune system is getting
weaker and weaker as we age right I mean
you know we you know people become more
susceptible to infections as they get
older uh and I think that that's equally
playing a role in our susceptibility to
cancer so yeah I think the question is
how do you modulate immunity
um as you age and to me that's one of
the most interesting things about rapy
potentially is that when taken the right
way it seems to enhance um cellular
immunity which again that that's
potentially a really big deal again at
least in in short-term human experiments
in response to vaccination it's
enhancing vaccine response so the
question is would that translate into
cancer nobody knows could that be one of
the reasons why animals treated with rap
ayin live longer and get less cancer
don't know you know it could also be
that it's it's at a fundamental level
that's targeting nutrient sensing um
where I was going with that story was
that and maybe I'll back up for a moment
why
melanoma so we didn't really know this
like 30 40 years ago in the early days
of
immunotherapy but what we know now is
that most cancers probably have about 40
mutations in them
that's like ballpark 4050 mutations is
standard fair for a cancer but melanoma
happens to be one of the cancers that
has many many more
mutations and the more mutations a
cancer has the more likelihood that it
will produce an antigen that's
recognized as
non-self and that's why in the early
days of immunotherapy the only things
that worked were I2 against metastatic
melanoma and kidney cancer because
kidney cancer turned out to also be one
of those cancers that for reasons that
are not clear produced hundreds of
mutations and so it's no surprise that
the early studies of checkpoint
Inhibitors were also done in metastatic
melanoma where you basically have more
shots on goal again if I'm going to take
the breaks off my immune system I might
as well do it in an environment where
there are more chances for my tea cells
to find something to go nuts
against so it's 2013 2014 and this
friend of mine who has something called
Lynch syndrome um which is a one of
those few hereditary or germline
mutations that results in a huge
increase in the risk of cancer he had
already had colon cancer at about the
age of 40 um and had survived that it
was a stage three cancer but he had
survived it well now five years later
had developed uh pancreatic cancer and
when he went to see the surgeon um they
said said yeah we there's nothing we can
do like it's too advanced so that's you
know to put that in perspective that is
a death sentence and that's not uh that
that's a that's a six-month
survival and at around that time there
was a study that had come out in the New
England Journal of Medicine that had
talked about how patients with Lynch
syndrome had lots of
mutations and so we you know talked with
his doctors about the possibility of
enrolling him in one of the Kuda trials
there was one going on I think at
Stanford and you know the thinking being
well you know you would want to Target a
checkpoint inhibitor against somebody
who has a lot of mutations and even
though typically we don't see that in
pancreatic cancer his is a unique
variant of it because it's based on this
and so sure enough he was tested for
these mismatch repair genes he had them
enrolled in the trial and amazingly had
not only a complete regression of his
cancer and he's still alive in cancer
free today 10 years later but this the
the the treatment worked so well at
activating his immune system that his
immune system completely destroyed his
pancreas so now he is effectively had a
pancreatectomy based on his immune
system so now he actually has Type 1
diabetes he has no pancreas he injects
insulin to deal with that or no he no no
he has to use insulin just like someone
with type di he had to pick being alive
with type one diabetes yeah of course no
comparison but it's just an interesting
example of how you know remarkable this
treatment was able to work when you were
you know you could completely unleash
the immune system of a person and you
eradicate the cancer and the rest of the
cells around it and and you know there
are many organs we could live without um
you know there are certain organs you
can't live without you can't live
without your heart lungs liver kidneys
um but but many things that kill people
arise from organs the breast you could
live without all breast tissue prostate
prostate you could live without all
prostate tiue would choose to do to live
without these but right but I'm saying
if you if if you had metastatic cancer
and you had a bullet that could
selectively Target a tissue you would
take it and right now the only tissue we
can do that against is a cd19 B cell and
that's what those car T cells are so
right now these are not tissue specific
treatments but they're mutation specific
what the last thing I'll say about this
paper that I found interesting and I I
was looking for it and I was surprised
they didn't at all comment on if there
was any correlation between autoimmunity
and
response um so they obviously
acknowledge the autoimmunity in in table
three but I would have loved to have
seen a statistical analysis that said
hey is there any correlation between
response rate and autoimmunity but um
they they didn't comment to that effect
so we're left kind of wondering what the
current state of that is and I guess in
summary I'll say that the reason I
thought this was an interesting paper to
present is that I still believe that
immuno theapy is probably the most
important hope we have for treating
cancer and well I think we're still only
scratching the surface of it so
collectively the overall survival
increase for patients with metastatic
solid organ tumors is about 8% better
than it was 50 years ago and virtu all
of that has come from some form of
immunotherapy um I think is promising
and I think the Holy Grail is the
meaning the next step if you go back to
where we started the
discussion is coming up with ways to
engineer te- cells to be even better
recognizers of antigens and there's many
ways to do that one is to directly
engineer them another is to find te-
cells that have already migrated into
tumors those are called tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes or
till and expanding those and Engineering
them to be better and younger is it
possible to engineer our own te- cells
to be more
pH variant tolerant meaning um since
this you know cloaking of the of a local
area by changing the pH can could we you
know pull some te- cells I'm I'm always
thinking about the inoculation stuff
like pull some te- cells as part of our
standard exam when we're 30 and um you
know and grow some up in an environment
that the pH is is slightly more acidic
than um than normal and then reintroduce
them to the body I mean after all they
are our tea cells um in other words give
them a little opportunity to
evolve the the conditions they can
thrive in right or even just keep them
in the freezer in case we need them yes
so so the interesting thing is I don't
know that if you just got them to be
comfortable in a lower p pH it would be
sufficient because there are still so
many other things that the uh cancer is
doing as far as using other secreting
factors um it seems that by far the most
potent thing comes down to expanding the
number of te- cells that recognize the
antigen and making sure that you can get
that number big enough without aging
them too much so in some senses it has
become a long longevity problem of te-
cells the way to think about it
is you want an army of soldiers who are
wise enough to recognize the bad guys
which comes with age but young enough to
go and kill and right now both extremes
seem to be unhelpful right when you go
and find tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
in a tumor they're very wise they know
which one they've demonstrated that they
can do everything they can outmaneuver
the cancer but they're too old to do
anything about it and when you take them
out to try to expand them by three logs
which is typically what you need to do
expand them by a thousandfold they can't
do anything got it and what about
avoiding melanoma altogether I mean
obviously avoiding sunburn you know I
somehow I got couched as anti-s
sunscreen and that is absolutely not
true I I said some sunscreens contain
things that are clearly immune disrupt
uh endocrine excuse me disruptors and
we're going to do a whole episode on
sunscreen maybe we could do some Journal
I'm actually planning something on that
as well I want and some dermatologists
reached out um some very very skilled
dermatologists reached out and said that
indeed some sunscreens are are downright
dangerous but of course melanoma is
super dangerous um physical barrier no
one disputes physical barriers for
sunscreen like everyone everyone agrees
that that is unlikely to have endrine
disruption um so physical barriers are
Undisputed but aside from limiting U
sunlight exposure to the skin um
what are some other risks for melanoma I
mean I think that's the biggest one I do
not believe that smoking poses a risk
for melanoma and if it does it's going
to be very small um there are hereditary
cases so one needs to be pretty mindful
when taking a family history and by the
way there are really weird genetic um
conditions that link melanoma to other
cancers such as pancreatic cancer by the
way so whenever I'm taking somebody's
family history and I hear about somebody
that had melanoma and someone that had
pancreatic cancer I'm there's a couple
genetics genetic tests we'll look at to
to see if that's a person that's
particularly sensitive just and a from a
genetic predisposition um but I do think
that first and foremost it's and by the
way I think with melanoma the although
it's not completely agreed upon I think
it's less about sun exposure and more
about
sunburn right so so and again I'm sure
there's somebody listening to this who
will chime in and apply a more nuanced
response to that um but but I think
there's a there's a fundamental
difference between I'm out in the sun
getting Sun making some vitamin D versus
I'm getting scorched and un you know
undergoing significant UV damage there
might also be something to be said for
the time in one's life and i' I've
certainly seen things that suggest that
early you know early repeated sunburns
would be more of a risk um so look I I
think that's not a controversial point
in the sense that like who wants to be
sunburned right so it's like whatever
one needs to do to be sunburned whether
it's you know you know being mindful of
what the UV index is wearing the
appropriate cover wearing the
appropriate sunscreen um I also find the
whole uh kind of anti-s sunscreen
establishment to be a little bit odd
well the anti sunscreen establishment is
odd you know I'm trying to open the door
for a Nuance discussion about you know
the fact that some sunscreens really do
contain things like oxy benzines and
things that are real and you're spraying
them on kids you just look at the
straight you know the good oldfashioned
mineral sunscreens um perfectly safe
yeah yeah as far as we know I mean I I
also uh dare we uh cross the seed oil
debate into this some of the folks who
are really anti- seed oil also claim
that seed oils increase risk for
sunscreen uh Peter and I are smiling
because we we have teed up uh a debate
soon with some you know anti-ed oil and
less anti-ed oil um experts so that
that's forthcoming that's going to be a
fun one we'll be doing all of that with
our shirts
on I really appreciate you um walking us
through this paper Peter I've never
looked at a paper on cancer um and
certainly not one like this um I learned
a lot and um it's such an interesting
field obviously because of the
importance of getting people with cancer
to survive longer and Lead better lives
but also um because of the the
interaction with the immune system so we
learned some really important immun ol
yeah and this was this was great I uh I
I feel much more confident now in the uh
belief that the the exposure to light
early and late in the day can actually
have have benefits and I and as I said I
think that there's I think there's
there's some causality here and I think
it shouldn't be ignored cool well this
was our second Journal Club I look
forward to our third next time you'll go
first we'll just keep alternating and
we've also switched venues but um we
both wore the the correct shirt uh and
um I hope uh people are learning um and
not just learning the information but
learning how to parse and think about
papers and I certainly learned from you
Peter thank you so much yeah thanks
Andrew this is great thank you for
joining me for today's Journal Club
discussion with Dr Peter AA if you're
learning from and or enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zeroc cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify bu Apple
you can leave us up to a fstar review
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast if you
have questions or comments for me or
guests or topics that you'd like me to
include on the hubman Lab podcast please
put those in the comments on YouTube I
do read all the comments not on today's
episode but on many previous episodes of
The hubman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep for hormone
support and for Focus to learn more
about the supplements on the hubman Lab
podcast you can go to live momentus
spelled o us so that's live mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am huberman lab on
all social media platforms so that's
Instagram Twitter now called X threads
LinkedIn and Facebook and on all of
those platforms I discuss science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the hubman
Lab podcast but much of which is
distinct from the content on the hubman
Lab podcast again that that's hubman lab
on all social media platforms if you
haven't already subscribed to our neural
network newsletter it is a zeroc cost
newsletter that includes summaries of
podcast episodes as well as protocols in
the form of brief 1 to three-page PDFs
for things like how to improve sleep how
to regulate dopamine deliberate cold
exposure deliberate heat exposure
exercise protocols and much more to sign
up simply go to hubman lab.com go to the
menu tab scroll down to newsletter and
provide us with your email and I want to
point out that we do not share your
email with anybody and again the
newsletter is completely zero cost thank
you once again for joining me for
today's Journal Club discussion with Dr
Peter Atia and last but certainly not
least thank you for your interest in
science